I've debated doing this
when I was pinned down by
a sniper in Afghanistan.
But there's no way that
enemy sniper would've hit that, though.
My name's Nicholas Irving.
I'm a former US Army Ranger
special-operations sniper.
I'm Command Sgt. Maj.,
retired, Lamont Christian.
I'm Nicholas Moran.
My name is Dakata Brodie.
Hey, everyone, Jay Ly here.
Hi, I'm John Spencer.
Gareth Timmins here.
I'm a former Royal Marines commando.
Today I'm back again to look
at some more sniper scenes
from TV and film,
rate tank battles,
urban warfare,
desert-warfare scenes,
boot-camp scenes,
helicopter-rescue scenes,
bomb-disposal scenes
in movies and TV and
judge how real they are.
Forrest: And always answer
every question with,
"Yes, drill sergeant."
Drill sergeant: Is that clear?!
Yes, drill sergeant!
The standard for responding
to a drill sergeant
is, "Yes, drill sergeant,"
"No, drill sergeant,"
and if it has to have
an affirmative response,
then the whole platoon
will sound just like that.
Done, drill sergeant!
Jesus H. Christ!
This is a new company record.
The drill sergeant was so
impressed because, you know,
in the early part of training,
it's a challenge for somebody
who perhaps has not
handled a weapon before,
what we would call weapons training,
to be able to take that weapon
apart, put it back together,
and do what you saw Forrest do there,
which was that functions check.
What your hope is as
a DI or drill sergeant
is that everybody in there
can do it like Forrest.
Shrimp and potatoes, shrimp burger.
What's funny is when
they're in there with them
with toothbrushes, that's
something of the past.
There was times where, you know,
you'd give a recruit scissors
and say, "Go cut the grass."
They're fostering this environment
of working together as a team,
which you saw with the weapons training,
which is what I call mindless repetition.
Just do it over and over and over again
until you get it right.
That has the same training
effect that this used to have.
The approach that the
drill sergeant had in here
was very, very common
for that time period,
during the Vietnam War.
So that's about a nine.
Pick it up! Move it! Move it!
I want to see some fire here!
When you look at obstacle courses,
usually in boot camp, you'll
go through them twice.
Obstacle courses are really designed
to find your upper-body strength
and also determine your endurance,
and so it may even test
your fear of heights,
fear of darkness, and then
you get to actually experience
the teamwork, helping each other.
You saw that a couple of times in there.
And definitely that screaming and yelling.
Often we call it simulating
battlefield conditions.
Drill sergeant: Create a loop.
This is the rabbit hole.
The rabbit comes out of his hole.
What is interesting is
ropes and knot tying
is no longer taught in basic training.
It is in Ranger School, though.
You're actually tested
in the mountain phase.
As things change over time,
there's certain requirements
that the leaders think that people need
upon finishing basic training.
This is to be your lover,
your mistress, your concubine,
perhaps the only thing in
life you'll ever truly love.
That's one of those things, again,
that you get from TV in Hollywood where
we place all of this level
of intimacy with our weapon.
Now, granted, it is an
intimate relationship
because you really want to be
confident with that weapon.
So taking it apart, putting it together
almost to the point where you
can do it blindfolded, right?
Talk about it in a way
that might be sexual,
that's kind of a Hollywood
thing that happens.
Oh, I'm sorry, sergeant.
I can't touch a gun.
For that time period, being World War II,
being a conscientious objector
was going to definitely be a challenge
for the leadership here.
This guy particularly is Desmond Doss.
He was actually a Medal
of Honor recipient,
and he didn't have to
carry a weapon to do it.
I would definitely say
this was a nine on realism.
Drill instructor: Can't
think when I'm giving you
a few love taps?
How the f--- are you
going to fire your rifle
when grenades are going off in your face?
Unfortunately, what we wind
up running into a lot of times
is drill sergeants or DIs like this one
that will touch and grab by the throat.
That was familiar in other DI movies.
Touching recruits in
training is unacceptable.
Always has been.
Sir, I got lost on the
way to college, sir!
That's exactly why, right there.
The open door that I could do even more,
and it turns to him slamming
the kid's head into a wall,
and that's why it's unacceptable.
Because where do you draw the line?
Them paintball bullets, they hurt?
Oh, s---!
Paintball is something,
as you notice there,
it was pretty painful.
That guy is going to
learn a valuable lesson
not to put himself in a window
if he's going to engage.
And so that's why paintball Simunitions,
is kind of what we call it,
is very, very useful in
the training environment.
Drill sergeant: The sounds
that you are hearing
are live rounds.
You will get the fear out of you.
Keep moving! Keep your head down!
Yeah, that's a trainer, a sergeant,
a leader's worst nightmare,
is to have somebody in
training lose their life.
Shooting the rounds over their head,
we actually do that, and
we also do it at night,
but the conditions are totally different.
The guns are raised up a whole lot higher,
and it's what we call a safe surface zone.
So even if you stood up
or jumped up and down,
it's almost 20 feet above
the heads of the individuals.
And, again, this tragedy right here,
as unfortunate as it is, it does happen
when those things are not adhered to.
For a boot-camp movie,
it's probably about a five.
Rusty bayonet, Liebgott.
Now, thanks to these men
and their infractions,
every man in the company who
had a weekend pass has lost it.
This is pretty neat,
because I actually served
as the command sergeant
major for this unit.
For the 2nd Battalion, 506th
Parachute Infantry Regiment
out of the 101st Airborne.
This right here is Easy Company
and their preparation for World War II.
During that time period in our military,
not many people were married, right?
And everybody was always looking for
a two-day or a three-day pass.
The stuff that they're being inspected on,
like this parade-level stuff,
and they're out there in combat gear,
I could see where he's going
with trying to instill discipline.
Just, I'm sure morale
is not going to be too high much longer.
Platoon: Stand alone! Stand alone!
Sobel: Do not help that man!
Do not help that man!
We ran this mountain a couple of times.
Currahee Mountain.
Yeah, it's no joke.
What I noticed here though, you know,
he was telling them to leave that guy.
Not leaving a fallen comrade,
that was part of the warrior ethos.
And never quitting.
So when you tie that together
in today's modern military,
leaving somebody behind would be something
that we wouldn't do.
That would be a 10 for
running up that hill.
And for World War II,
it'd probably be about a eight in realism.
Drill sergeant: "Yes,
drill sergeant, and "No,
drill sergeant." Do I make myself clear?
Recruits: Yes, drill sergeant!
You get them in the barber
chair, spin them around,
they had no hair.
Like, that's even part of a
military cadence sometimes.
The males, anyway, are
getting their hair cut
where they cut it all the way down.
Female recruits are not required.
And believe it or not,
it's a health and hygiene issue, right?
Because you get people that
come from all walks of life,
and so you don't know necessarily
if they have, like, head lice
or any other type of issues
underneath all the hair.
Cherry: Next we got
about 100 f---ing shots.
You just get shots until you
get all the way to the end
and you're completely inoculated
against every disease known to man, right?
Execute.
Drill sergeant: Move, goddamn
it! Move! Let's go, move!
The difference that I could
see so far in this scene is
they have them all
taking their clothes off
in an open room or an open bay.
It wouldn't be done that
way at what they call
a military entrance processing
station, or the MEPS.
All military members go through there,
and there's no drill sergeants there.
It's just a staff of military personnel,
administrators, doctors, counselors,
because what they're doing
is they're determining
whether or not you're fit to train.
Cherry: They had us strip
down to our underwear
and duckwalk the circuit of a big room.
Oh, yeah, duckwalking.
I remember the first time I did that.
I was like, "What in the world?"
They have you walk from one
side of the room to the other,
and the doctor is looking
for your bone structure,
your musculoskeletal development,
if you're flat-footed, also
just your mobility and agility.
But yeah, you definitely
wouldn't be in a room like that
full of other people. Be hard to assess.
I would have to say it's
about a four, right?
Because that's not necessarily
how that whole indoctrination process
would happen with the drill sergeants.
If you survive recruit
training, you will be a weapon.
You will be a minister
of death praying for war.
So far this is looking pretty good.
Because in the DIs in the Marine Corps,
they actually have a script.
They say, "You'll sit up
straight and look at me!"
So while the difference in the titles,
the drill instructor was
tied into the Marine Corps.
Drill sergeants came
into play for the Army.
And the interaction in the
first part of boot camp
is always going to be what
we call total control.
Everywhere you look,
there's going to be some DI
or drill sergeant
ensuring that the training
that has been given is being reinforced.
And so when you see R. Lee
Ermey walking around in the bay,
he's doing exactly what a DI would do.
He actually was a drill
sergeant, as a matter of fact.
He served several years during
the Vietnam War as a DI.
You maggots understand that?
Sir, yes, sir!
Bulls---! Can't hear you!
If you notice, the DI
is constantly yelling,
and it's not because they
like yelling at individuals,
it's just so they don't have to repeat
the same commands over and over.
So if you have a recruit
on one end of the bay,
he or she is going to
hear the instructions
all the way on the other end of the bay.
5-foot-9, I didn't know
they stacked s--- that high.
You trying to squeeze an
inch in on me somewhere? Huh?
Another thing that you
often see in these movies
and TV shows is the DI
or the drill sergeant
doing a lot of cursing and swearing.
Cursing and swearing is not
something that is acceptable,
but it does happen.
For that Vietnam era,
that's pretty realistic.
Now you have people who are
deciding to serve their country,
and it's a different view.
I was part of the committee
that created the change,
what we called shock and awe,
commonly called a shark attack,
as opposed to this fallacy, which was
we have to break them down
in order to build them up,
and focus more on the teamwork.
And so that's what The 100
Yards was designed to do.
Day one, here's a challenge.
Pop that blister!
Lamont: Mm-hmm.
Part of that indoctrination
when the DI comes in
is the wellness of the
trainees or the recruits,
and so they have to inspect the feet,
inspect the hands,
and make sure that there's no open sores.
What the f--- is that?
What is that, Pvt. Pyle?
Sir, a jelly doughnut, sir!
We've gone away from footlockers
and modularized most of
the equipment in the bay.
So you wouldn't necessarily
have a footlocker in the bay,
and he definitely wouldn't be standing
on the equipment like that.
They have this term in the
Army they call "toe the line,"
and that's where they actually
stand next to the line
so that they can do that inspection.
From now on, whenever Pvt. Pyle f---s up,
I will not punish him.
I will punish all of you!
Yep, there we go.
Especially in the beginning
phases of boot camp,
the DI and the drill sergeant
is going to definitely dole out punishment
as a mass punishment, even
though one person may mess up.
This opportunity for
somebody to have looked
and held Pyle accountable
for that doughnut was missed,
and that's what the DI is reinforcing.
We'll hold each other accountable.
I would have to say it was probably
about a nine for that era.
If we're talking in today's terms,
it'd probably be about a seven in realism.
We are going to win this war
because we have the best men.
When they were standing in formation
and the leader stopped and
kind of looked at this guy
and he looks like a middle-school kid,
there was actually a guy named Flaherty.
This guy was 4 feet 9 inches,
and they called him The Giant Killer
because of all the different exploits
that he did during Vietnam.
And he was smaller than Rogers was, right?
Nobody's got that flag in 17 years!
Yo, the smallest guy in the formation
wound up coming up with
the plan of success.
In the basic-training environment,
you probably wouldn't have
that type of situation
placed on a trainee or a recruit.
That's some
special-missions-type unit stuff
that's going on there where
an assessment is being done, right?
Because they want to know if
you have a special skill set.
What they were actually
doing in the training
would not necessarily be something
that you would see in recruit training.
So I'm going to give it a five.
Left! Face!
Yeah, that's the campaign hat
or the famous drill sergeant hat.
I just happen to have mine with me,
and, you know, there's
distinct headgear that is worn
by the male drill sergeants in the Army,
but then also by the male and
female DIs in the Marines.
What's unique is, while all the branches
except the Navy have some
form of a campaign hat,
the Army still has a separate hat
for the female drill sergeant.
It's called a bush hat.
A-left, a-left, right, left.
♪ There she was just
walking down the street ♪
♪ Singing do wah diddy
diddy dum diddy do ♪
That part where the one
character starts singing
that diddy bop, it's
interesting that most cadences,
that's actually where
they come from, right?
Popular tunes, R&B music, I
mean, even nursery rhymes.
Even my own voice has
been tapped into a cadence
in the Gatorade commercial
singing the hard work cadence.
♪ Work, work ♪
♪ Hard work ♪
So these guys, they're just, you know,
jumping in on a bandwagon,
throwing in the diddy bop
in there at the same time.
Razzle dazzle!
Hut, two, three, four!
Yeah, that ain't happening.
However, in the Army,
in what we call the advanced
individual training,
which, those periods of
training go from six weeks
to six months, maybe even a year,
drill and ceremony
competitions are usually used
to continue to motivate those individuals
that have the longer periods of training.
But not as likely in a
basic combat training
because we're focusing on
shooting, moving, communicating,
and treating yourself and
others on the battlefield.
I'd have to say a four.
Locate a wounded soldier,
represented by a dummy.
You must then transport him to
the emergency field hospital.
There's a lot going on there so far.
When it started out, it
definitely was something
that you would see in recruit training.
You know, a lot of female leaders now
are in positions of senior leadership,
something that hadn't
occurred over many years,
until the military had
started really opening up
the ranks of the infantry
to our female leaders.
An aggressor team will
be trying to stop you.
They are all awaiting ranger training
and can't wait to capture you.
Based on what the information
and the instructions they were given,
it's actually an advanced
individual training.
You know, medical training.
They're not going to be
as complex with a mission
that would go that deep,
and that was evident
when I saw them in the river there,
because the risk for, you
know, perhaps somebody drowning
or something else with
all that equipment on,
then not too many people
are going to want to
put a recruit in that type of environment.
Again, the risk factors
wouldn't be something
that you'd see in recruit training,
but definitely something
very similar challenging-wise
as far as the military's concerned.
You know, Marines have a Crucible,
and the Army has this
thing called The Forge.
Very similar, in the final
test of all of the training
that they receive during
the recruit training.
And there are medical lanes
where they might have to treat
a casualty or transport a
casualty, like you saw here,
to really see if all of the training
has actually reached the
point where they are confident
that these individuals can leave
and go to their next assignment.
I have to give that a
five as far as realism.
♪ Casey Jones was a son of a b---- ♪
Hazing is something that,
again, has never been accepted,
but it happens.
This is depicting an
environment where there's still
initial entry training or
initial military training,
but it's Officer Candidate School.
Typically, officer candidates
are a little bit more mature,
have either been in the
military for quite some time
and reached enlisted ranks.
There's levels of hazing
that may be more acceptable
in that environment
versus in the recruit training.
So there was a mandate
that provided leadership
across all of the branches to come up with
progressive ways, if you would,
in order to attack and
get in front of hazing.
And so whether it was
reporting, such as in the Army,
you know, Not in My Squad,
to place accountability
not just on leadership, but on each other.
No, sir!
Drill sergeant: DOR!
I ain't gonna quit!
Right, then you can forget it!
You're out!
Don't you do it!
There's about two or three
layers of checks and balances
so that you don't have that
rogue DI or rogue drill sergeant
who might take something personal
like it looks like in this clip.
Because of the flexibility and the things
that take place in the
Officer Candidate School
versus what happens in recruit training
for initial entry training,
I would say that it's
probably about a seven.
All right, Shirley, you can drop them now.
Weight training has always been something
that's important in the military
to be able to carry your body weight.
And in some cases, you
might have to lift or carry
or drag somebody else.
The sand buckets and them
using them for weights,
a lot less expensive than
buying weights for every Marine.
But then they get the same
physical exercise out of it.
Drill instructor: See the jab? Outside?
Right into the body once again.
Working with the blade.
They were doing combatives,
right, with the pugils,
and then the drill instructor
was showing them with the
knife close-quarter combat,
because every Marine, every soldier,
every person that joins the military
is a fighter first, right?
And so pugil stick training
is one of those ways
that that confidence is
instilled in the individual
and their ability to stand their ground.
And it's also fun to look at.
I would say it's about a seven.
Greetings all, I'm Nicholas Moran.
I commissioned as an
armor officer for M1 tanks
and then converted to M3 Bradleys.
These days, I work as a
civilian vehicle historian,
primarily for World of Tanks.
The Ripsaw, which was
basically a tracked toy
for people to drive around in,
looks just like it does in the movie here.
It's because it had such lightweight
and such a high-powered weight ratio,
the thing is incredibly
fast and incredibly nimble,
which of course, attracts the
attention of the military,
well, hang on a second.
We've got this vehicle
that can go anywhere
really, really quickly. Can
we do something with it?
But the variant that the
Army has been looking at
of late is actually a
robotic combat vehicle.
I believe it's the RCVM,
and it's being plugged
as the M5, and on the top,
much like is shown in the clip,
is a remote weapon station.
He's driving on ice, and those
don't look like ice tracks.
Believe it or not, there's
actually ways you can get
more grip on a tracked vehicle on ice.
It's anything from snow chains,
those used in World War II,
to these days, you can have grousers
that you knock out a few track pads,
and you put basically
cleats into the track.
This thing is going quite fast
doing its various maneuvers
on ice, and that's
questionable in this context.
I can think of no reason
except for an accession to plot
why a tank would have a
grappling hook attached to it.
The Lambo at the point
that they connect is
basically underwater, and
that provides more drag
than this thing can haul.
Well, that's your point for realism.
The door came off instead of
the Lambo getting pulled out.
I'm going to be generous.
I'm going to give it one
point because it has tracks.
And I'm going to give it one point
because it pulled the door
instead of the whole Lambo,
so I'm going to give it a two.
So you will have seen the
Americans had somebody standing
on the back firing the caliber .50.
The caliber .50 was originally
put onto American vehicles
as an anti-aircraft weapon.
And the reason that it's
on that external mount
at the back is that it's a
lot easier to aim upwards
if you're standing on the
back deck and then aiming up,
as opposed to trying to stick
your head out of the hatch
and maybe put it down from the side
and you're not even
able to use the sights.
Shermans!
One of the things Sherman was
very good at was showing up
when you needed a tank,
and they tended not to go
around in ones and twos.
They tended to go around in fives and 17s.
Yeah, sure, on a tank-on-tank duel,
it wasn't necessarily the best.
For an infantryman that's
under heavy attack,
he doesn't care if the best
tank in the world shows up,
as long as the tank which
shows up a) actually arrives,
and b) is good enough to deal
with whatever the
infantryman's problem is.
So you'll notice that the
Germans don't actually have
any tanks, which was a
problem that the Germans had
in World War II, is that their
industry simply wasn't up
to the levels of American or Russian.
So what we have here are a lot
of assault guns and tank destroyers.
It looks like a Marder there,
or at least a representation
of one, a Sturmgeschütz,
which is an assault gun,
and a Jagdpanther.
The Jagdpanther is the only
one that is the serious threat
to an allied vehicle.
Why didn't the Jagdpanther
just sit there and place
its extremely tough frontal
armor to the Shermans?
Well, you could do that,
but then you were probably now
placing your weak flank armor
to the American infantry, who are equipped
in the scene with bazookas,
anti-tank rocket launchers.
The Germans now are flanked,
and so very sensibly,
they immediately abandon the
attack and start falling back.
This is as good as you're going to get
on celluloid or on digits.
If there is ever going to be a 10
for "rate a tank battle,"
this is probably it.
The tanks represent Saint-Chamond.
There's only one that exists in the world.
It's at the French national
tank museum in Saumur.
Now, the cognoscenti will look
at the road wheels on that
and realize that the vehicle is based off
a BMP or an MT-LB, which are
Soviet Cold War vehicles.
By this point in the war, we're talking
towards the end of 1918, the
Germans are very familiar
with tanks, but you'll still
want to shoot them anyway
for a couple of reasons.
One is if the tanks are
accompanying infantry,
well, you're going to have
an effect on the infantry
and maybe suppress them to the point
that the tanks are going
to advance on their own.
Secondly, the tanks were not
the most robust at the time.
There was a problem known
as splash, especially when
once the tankers would actually
wear a type of chain mail
in front of their face with
goggles to stop the pieces
of bullet coming in the gaps in the armor.
Finally, it's psychological.
It makes you feel a lot better
to actually do something,
even if it's a gesture of futility.
The early tank guns for
World War I would have
generally either been
converted artillery pieces
or, quite often, naval guns.
The big problem you're going to have
with getting them close
is called depression.
So there is a stop as to how
far down the gun will depress,
and that determines how close you can get
to the enemy trench before you
can have to stop engaging it.
To this date, trench-crossing
ability in terms of meters,
how many meters of
trench you can cross, is
still a criterion.
The idea of can you cross
it without collapsing it,
well, that depends if you
want to collapse it or not.
So even as late as the Iraq campaigns,
a tank would go up to
fortified enemy position,
turn on the spot, and
bury the people inside.
And it's one of those unfortunate
realities of basically,
tanks have many ways of killing you,
and the tracks are one of them.
You'd think today a hand grenade
isn't going to do very much.
The tracks on the
Saint-Chamond were basically
for my whole tractor, so
they weren't as battle-proof
as a modern vehicle would be.
In fact, the armor on
this is so thin that a lot
of heavy bullets, they even
developed rifle bullets
with an armor-piercing core could go
through these early tanks.
This is an eight and a half, maybe nine.
I could quibble a few things,
but it generally gets the concept across.
Oh, goody.
So Rambo has gotten into his,
I'm going to call it a T-72.
It's not actually,
but the helicopter here represents a Hind.
I think it's actually
a Puma, but the Hind,
the Mi-24, was a gunship
that still actually has
a troop-carrying capacity,
as well as carrying a lot
of rockets and missiles
and being heavily armored.
It's basically a flying tank,
for lack of a better term.
So hang on, is he
driving, or is he gunning?
There's only one tank that I can think of
that is fully combat-capable
with one crewman,
and that is the Swedish Strv 103,
commonly known as the S-tank.
The driver functions
as the gunner as well,
and this is why you're supposed to go
with anti-aircraft vehicles
in company with you,
because their job is to defend
you against air threats.
So our enemy is in an attack
helicopter, a gunship,
and it's got missiles on the
tips, AT-2 Swatters probably,
that are effective from
several kilometers away.
And instead, he's firing unguided rockets
at the front of the Rambo tank.
Why doesn't he just fly
around the back and shoot
the rockets into the engine
deck or the rear turret,
or you know, some place
that'll actually cause damage?
And so the enemy pilot dies the death
that his stupidity deserved.
Officially, if you must
charge towards an aircraft,
do it at an angle.
He has to not only aim for lead,
but also the change in
distance at the same time.
Whereas if you're
charging straight at him,
you're simplifying the problem
for the aircraft that's coming at you.
He doesn't need to worry about aiming.
It has a tank, so I'll give it a one.
Fire.
The premise of an ambush
in an urban setting by
armor is not unheard of,
but the idea of armor
operating in an urban setting
without infantry support
is normally questionable.
Panthers are not well suited
for close-range fighting.
They really would excel
on the Eastern Front,
well, the steppes of Ukraine, for example,
nice long lines of fire.
That said, they can get
away with it in this context
because they know that
the enemy is a single tank
with no infantry.
Oh look, you're going
through a building again,
except this time he's
done one thing right.
He's got the turret
traversed over the rear.
I'd mentioned before, you don't want to go
through a building if you can avoid it.
In this case, I guess they couldn't,
because they're getting shot at.
And if you are going to go
through, spin your turret over,
and you'll keep yourself safe.
And what you can see here,
the T-34-85 has a very
neat traverse handle,
so it performs two functions.
In this case, you can see
he has it in manual mode,
cranking around, as
opposed to electric mode,
which, you simply flip
the handle 90 degrees.
However, maybe the gunner
just doesn't know this,
because in the movie,
this was a found tank.
Even myself, when I got into
a T-34-85 for the first time,
and trying to see where is
the second control handle,
I can't find it.
This is quite feasible.
When faced with the Panther
in this close range,
T-34 crew now has a choice.
It can either run away, or
it can attempt to engage.
Now, I would probably agree
with the 34 crew on this for two reasons.
One, the Panther was looking
the wrong way entirely.
And the other thing is Panthers
are not the easiest thing
in the world to kill,
unless you can get around
the side or behind them.
And in this case, they're
already behind them,
so why not engage?
But the only thing I might have
done differently was back up
two or three tank lengths
and aim the gun into the engine deck.
That would be a more guaranteed kill
than trying to aim for the turret ring.
So the explosion was
actually a little bit faster
than what would really happen.
Generally speaking, when a
tank is hit, it takes a couple
of seconds, and those are
your couple of seconds
that is the difference
between life and death
when you're getting out of a vehicle.
Although in reality, the
net-effect difference
to the crew is academic.
They're basically toast.
In this context, I don't
know, maybe a seven.
The movie is set about the
time of the Yemeni civil war.
It's actually kind of still ongoing.
The film was made in Morocco,
hence, you have the M60s and
the T-72s. So the exact nature
of the tanks that you get in
Yemen isn't entirely there,
but hey, for movie purposes,
it gets the point across.
Certainly there are Western
and Eastern tanks in the area.
Tank Alpha, attack from the right!
Hong Xu!
Turn 20 degrees left, hurry!
So what I have here is
a VIC-1 CVC, combat
vehicle crewman, helmet.
And the reason you would
want to wear a helmet
even if you're inside
the tank is quite simply,
you're being thrown around,
and there's a lot of sharp,
pointy things sticking out at you
that as you're being thrown around,
you don't want to hurt your head.
And of course, you also
have the dust goggles,
because the tanks are throwing
a lot of dust up at you.
You don't have a windshield.
If you're doing 40 miles an hour,
there's still enough
wind that you'll notice,
so you wear a set of goggles, as well.
It's good to see armor actually work.
So what has happened there is a round hit
explosive reactive armor. So
those bricks that you see,
and what they generally consist of,
though this is a gross oversimplification,
is a couple of pieces of metal sandwiching
a piece of explosive, and
that when a round hits it,
it explodes and disrupt or destabilize it
to the extent that the main
armor belt behind can stop it.
Turn right!
Nan Xia, get ready!
Fire!
You got a couple of problems.
Firstly, if the entire
turret system is off line,
then the tank is still
rocking a little bit.
It may not look it much, but
it's going to be rocking enough
that he cannot hip-shoot
a 125 on a point target
like a tank like that.
Secondly, he literally is hip-shooting,
and he's eyeballing it.
I don't see why he couldn't
still be using the gunsight.
He can then pull the trigger himself.
Sandstorms do happen.
In the 2003 invasion
of Iraq, there was one
that basically shut down the
war for a couple of days.
Well, your big problem with a
sandstorm is the air filters.
So the sand is going to
get into your air filters
and clog them up very quickly.
However, in this context,
I don't think they had
a heck of a lot of choice,
because being chased
by a platoon of M60s,
they were probably going to die anyway,
so why not make for the
sandstorm and hope for the best?
So I think seven's probably fair.
I'm not even sure where to start.
I'm trying to think of any
reasonable military context
that this vehicle could exist in.
The US Army has a vehicle, the
M1117, which is a derivative
of the old LAV-100s from Vietnam.
It's basically a huge, armored 4-by-4
with a gun turret on the
top for military police use.
I'm sure they wouldn't
mind something like this.
So generally speaking, convoys,
just because of the nature
of roads, you tend to be in
column instead of line abreast
like in the shot here.
You have a bit of a choice,
depending on how many vehicles
you have, is how far apart
you want the vehicles to be.
Because the idea is that
your lead vehicle is going
to be sufficiently far in
front of whatever it is
that you're protecting the
main body of the convoy.
So with only three vehicles,
you're kind of limited
as to what you can do, but
your typical is going to be
maybe two up front, then the main asset,
and then one bringing up the rear.
Cannons are not common,
but they are a thing.
You can sometimes find
them mounted as experiments
on tanks as well, but
they're basically a waste
of space and weight, so you
don't see them on tanks.
In terms of a missile launcher,
yeah, missile launchers on
armored cars are a thing.
This particular elevating
out of the 4-by-4 is
probably closer to a
BRDM anti-tank system,
but that's actually for
anti-armor purposes,
not anti-aircraft.
But hey, I guess when
you're dealing with Batman,
anything goes.
I got nothing. Zero. Sorry. No.
The Germans appear to be
equipped with Pak 40s.
It was a very good anti-tank
gun, 7.5 cm caliber,
definitely a valid threat against an M4.
Anti-tank! H.E.! Traverse left.
Traverse left!
That was a doctrinal fire command.
Now, the reason I know this
is they actually sent me
the script for filming
it. But that is basically
alert, target, and command of execution
in abbreviated fire command.
The fire commands back in
World War II weren't quite
as regimented as they are today,
but the fundamentals are
actually still the same.
You have an argument.
Do you want to advance
over open ground as a whole platoon,
or do you want to bound in sections?
In this case, because of
the amount of infantry
that they're trying to provide cover for,
I can see perhaps why they
went as a full platoon on line.
But also, it's a very,
very open, long field,
so maybe it was necessary
for the entire platoon
to advance on line simply so
that they could see the target.
Another gun, who's got eyes on it?
Somebody's going to ask,
how can a Pak 40 miss
at such short range?
You'll be surprised what
stress is going to do to you.
So there have been
studies, and the reputation
of the 88 is such that it doesn't miss.
In reality, they're firing 20
rounds to get a single kill,
because the stress of combat
is such that it is not
calm and collected on a gunnery range
when you're doing scientific testing.
It's, "Oh God, I'm about to die."
Let's light them up. Let's
go. Let's clean it up.
Now, that scene is basically
why I became a tanker.
A line of tanks, every machine gun going.
A single tank is considered
to have firepower
more or less equivalent
to an infantry platoon,
because you have the
heavy machine gun up top,
you got a co-ax machine gun,
you got a bow machine gun,
and oh, by the way, you've got a cannon.
That is a lot of firepower
from a single vehicle,
and you can imagine this sheer suppression
and psychological effect
that comes of this,
let alone the lethal effects.
I know there were folks that didn't like
that I gave the last "Fury" a nine,
but I'm giving this one a nine as well.
I can't get elevation and he knows it.
So this was an actual
problem in Afghanistan,
and it's a mountainous
country, is that their tanks,
which were designed
really for open warfare
on the plains of Germany,
can't elevate high enough.
So what the Soviets ended
up doing was they developed
a variant of the ZSU-23-4
anti-aircraft gun,
the Shilka, called the Afghani.
So they would use those in conjunction
with the tanks to provide
that close-range, high-elevation security
that Daskal here is having a problem with.
The actual effect of hitting
the gun tube is not going to be
the petaling like you see
here. That's for visual effect.
What you're actually going
to get is a very small hole
that goes through the gun tube,
but it's still plenty bad enough
that you've disabled the gun.
The grenade will not have
separated the tracks,
so I must conclude it was the rocks,
but it's not impossible for rocky terrain
and maybe a less experienced
driver to angle his track
in such a way when he's turning
that he gets rocks caught
in between the wheels and the
tracks and snaps the track pin,
and that throws your track and loses it.
This scene is probably
a seven to an eight.
My name's Nicholas Irving.
I'm a former US Army Ranger
special-operations sniper.
I'm also known as The Reaper
for my 33 confirmed kills in Afghanistan.
Eve: I may have a shot.
Absolutely not.
She's offhand. Like, there's no support.
It's all muscling it in to make that shot.
And that gun, well, yeah, that's, no.
The Olympic Arms
K23B is what it is.
That weapon is literally accurate
for up to, like, 50 meters.
That distance looks like it's about,
at most, a couple of hundred yards.
Put it back in the case and go
back and get a different one.
It's not clean.
Repeat, I do not have a clean shot.
Yeah I don't think she
had a clean shot at all.
In the military a clean shot would be,
you're not going to
wound or injure or kill
something you don't intend to.
If her target is one of those two men,
that bullet, you know, it's a 5.56.
It's going to zip right
through the bad guy
and potentially wound or kill
the guy she's trying to help out or save.
M: I said take the shot.
I can't. I may hit Bond.
Take the bloody shot!
If I was forced to take this
shot, I'll pull the trigger,
but I'm not going to
guarantee you anything.
Luckily the train does
kind of come towards her,
as opposed to moving left or right.
That takes out so much
more of the mathematics
behind making a shot.
When it's moving closer or away from you,
it's all about just
aiming above the target
or a little bit below the target,
as opposed to, you know,
aiming in front of it
and having that individual
essentially run into the bullet.
I would rate it a one.
Like, it's just not happening at all.
That little good tactical
deep-breath pause
before the shot was really good.
To be more precise, you
essentially have to be calm,
and one of the easiest
ways to calm your body down
right before a shot is
to just take deep breaths
and get the blood circulating.
I would've got more
square behind the rifle,
as opposed to having my legs
off to the side like that.
Maybe got down in a squatting
stance or on my knees
and kind of put my weight behind the gun.
That way when it recoils
it's kind of more of
a straight-back motion
and not this motion.
He's going to pretty much get that
just because of his body alignment
and the way he's holding the rifle.
Mike: There you go.
Yeah, I think it was smart for him
to let the vehicle get closer to him.
Everybody thinks being a sniper,
we want the longest, furthest shots,
but ideally, you want the closer ones
just because it makes
your job that much easier
and it's almost like 100%
guarantee you're going to hit.
But with that, if I'm protecting someone
and I shoot the vehicle
within a few yards from them,
the guy is still going to get
hit by the moving vehicle.
I don't like that the car
just did a triple axel,
like, 20 feet from the guy.
Like, that's not how that works at all.
The only moving vehicles that I've shot,
I was a machine gunner.
And I've never once made a car flip over.
Normally they just crash into a wall
or crash into another parked car
or just roll off the side
of the road into the desert.
I'd give it a six.
The only thing that's pulling me back
or giving it a lesser number
is because of the sniper
waiting for the car to get closer.
I mean, as far as being a
highly accurate sniper rifle
concealed as a flute, I don't think so.
There's a lot of big
things on a sniper rifle
that makes it accurate, but
the barrel is really important,
and most barrels on sniper
rifles are fluted and floated.
There's no interference between the barrel
and the stock of the gun,
as to not interfere with the
harmonics when it goes off.
That flute looks like one
continuously long, long object.
It probably is accurate,
maybe at the distances
that he's shooting at,
but I also don't know what
caliber he's shooting.
But it's Tom Cruise, so it's
probably really accurate.
I'd give the female
sniper the best position.
Whatever she's in,
that little room or the
designs on the walls,
I think that really
gives her an advantage,
and it almost is like
shooting out of a loophole.
It's like a tactic snipers used overseas
where you punch a small hole
through a wall or something
and a sniper would back away from the wall
and shoot through that hole
to hit an object outside.
The guy with the shades on,
well, he's not really
in a concealed position,
but I guess he's using his attire
to make him least stand out.
Worst position, I'd
have to say Tom Cruise.
Any sniper rifle can be suppressed,
even up to, like,
.50-caliber sniper rifles.
You're still going to hear a noise.
It sounds like a clap, a loud clap,
or if you took a ruler
and smacked it on a desk.
Unless you use, like, subsonic rounds,
which he may be using in this instance,
where I could see nobody else
would really hear anything.
Shooting lights are actually
extremely hard to do.
Like, that was one of our
things overseas sometimes.
When an assault team is
going up on a building,
they want the lights shot out for them
to make it dark, and that's,
it's actually pretty tough
because it blurs out everything,
and it's hard to find exactly,
I guess, where the middle is at.
I'll give it a five.
Those shots are, you know, possible,
but I don't think that this
scenario, setup is that realistic.
I grew up watching this movie.
It's one of the reasons why
I wanted to become a sniper.
Every sniper, you have your rifle
and you have your ghillie suit.
What it essentially does
is break up the outline
of the human body and mimics
or makes you appear to be
brush or foliage.
But it's not just the ghillie suit
that's what makes you camouflage.
What you're going to really want to do
is put a bunch of natural
vegetation into the ghillie suit
so you look more like
the natural surrounding,
as opposed to just this
big pile of ghillie suit.
Sniper: Three to five on the legs.
You have the spotter
and you have the sniper.
The spotter's the one who's
not pulling the trigger,
and he's holding up a, or
using a spotting scope.
Through his, it looked
like a red-dot camera thing
or something like that,
and that's just not what it looks like.
Either you're going to have a reticle
that mimics or is similar
to what the sniper's using.
These mil dots or radian
lines are going to
give you your distance
and be able to track
where the bullet impacts.
He's moving.
Sniper: 650. Range me.
Being a sniper, like,
80% to 90% of your job
is observation. It's actually really rare
that a sniper does get a
chance to pull the trigger.
Most of our stuff is just
relaying information,
watching stuff, taking pictures,
and telling the commanders
what's going on on the ground.
So you can be out there for
as long as the job needs.
I think everything he
did there was just fine.
Looks like he's using an
M24 sniper rifle, could be,
or something similar to that, a variant,
but they're good out to, like, 800 meters.
At 650 yards, like, that's not,
that's far, but it's not
that far for a sniper.
And a body shot, which is
what I'd normally aim for,
was perfect.
Like, that's all you're going
to go for at that distance.
My only issue, would
probably have something soft
underneath his rifle,
maybe put down a pack
or his backpack or
something to rest it on.
That helps with the harmonics
and having the rifle bounce
and get all the way from you.
I'll give it a seven. I was
going to give it an eight,
but a seven because the sniper scope
and the reticles and all that stuff
just didn't make any sense.
To stay still when you're
pinned down by a sniper,
it's almost a death wish.
It's just a matter of
time before he's going to
figure something out to
make those bullets impact.
Running zigzag patterns,
getting out as fast as you
can is probably your best bet.
To prevent an enemy coming in
to do what just happened
here, sneak up behind you,
in sniper school they teach you
no more than, like, two shots.
Two or three shots, your
sniper hide is burnt.
You would want to move
ideally to a new location.
Once you have a good sniper hide set up,
the odds of you getting
out after that second shot,
third shot, it's slim.
But there are countermeasures
to deter people
from entering that sniper hide.
Like, for us, we might put up
a Claymore or some booby traps
or something like that behind us,
or even a guy with a machine gun
is usually watching our back.
That actually wasn't too bad,
and it's at nighttime
with no night vision,
so I'll give him that.
We hit targets at nighttime,
but the distances are extremely close.
We had a sniper scope that was
mounted with a PVS-14, I believe,
which is a night-vision attachment
that goes on the front of your scope.
Bolt guns, bolt rifles,
they jam all the time,
especially in dusty conditions.
That bolt gun, when you pull it back,
it's exposed to the elements.
And it's such a slower process
as opposed to, like, a semiautomatic,
where the bolt is coming
back extremely fast.
So it's more prone to collect dust
and things of that nature
that would cause it to jam up.
Man, this is getting tough.
I don't know. I'd give it a six because,
realistically, shooting
at nighttime like that,
I could see you missing that much.
I've debated doing this
when I was pinned down by
a sniper in Afghanistan,
taking my helmet off.
If that's your last resort
and all you're trying to do
is locate a sniper's position,
I would've probably stuck my helmet up on
the tip of my gun and dangled
it up, as opposed to throw it.
I might need that for later.
But there's no way that enemy sniper
would've hit that, though.
Like, back in World War II,
snipers used to use the trees
to hide in and shoot from,
and there really is no
benefit to hiding in a tree.
Once they find you out,
all they have to do is
center all their guns onto
that tree and chop it down.
Hiding underneath the tree
or in the hole of the tree,
where some of them get
hollowed out, I could see that.
But I'm scared of bugs,
so that's not for me.
As far as taking the shot when he took it,
nine times out of 10, if
a sniper's being sent out,
it's to overwatch his guys
and make sure nothing happens to them.
But if we're already engaged in targets
and we're already being shot at,
then anything that's
moving on that opposite end
that is a threat or has a
weapon is going to get shot.
So, yeah, he had every right
to pop a few rounds off at this guy.
I would have too.
I'd give it a nine,
just because I've been in
a situation where I debated
taking my helmet off
and using it as a decoy.
Isaac: I don't f---ing know!
So, I was an on-set tech
advisor on this film
and also played the dead guy
that he got the radio from.
Should've won an award for it.
Best dead guy ever.
But that sand was real.
We were really in the
desert, and it was brutal.
It's extremely hard to aim through,
we call it a brownout,
where it's just, like, a semi,
little, I guess dust storm
that rose, so you can't see anything.
So he's definitely not going
to be able to make a shot,
especially at the distances
that he's going for
with that much dust blowing
around, obscuring his vision.
Isaac: Give me max plus four!
Six mils right!
I'm not going to say it's impossible
to take out an enemy sniper
who's hiding among stuff like that.
The hardest thing the good sniper
is going to have to do is locate him.
From what I remember,
I recall it being over 1,000 meters away,
which is extremely, extremely far
to be conducting a
countersniper operation.
The sound of the rifle
that John Cena is firing,
in the movie is not how
it sounds in real life.
Like, this sounds like
a semiautomatic rifle
with a suppressor on it
or something like that.
In real life, that gun is
just a big thunderous boom,
a big bang.
The way he was shooting in the movie,
it's kind of like it's a semiautomatic,
as opposed to him cranking
the bolt back every time,
and the sound is off.
Did you get him?
Please tell me you got him --
Yeah, he was dead from the get-go.
Like, shooting in an open area
and a sniper has eyes on you,
there's really nothing you can do about it
unless you are going to get up and just
take a chance and run for it.
Just crawling away slowly wouldn't work.
He's just going to watch you crawl
and decide when to shoot anyways.
So it's a lose-lose.
This scene here, I don't
think I worked that day,
so [laughs].
No, I only have so much control,
but this scene I would rate, like, a ...
oh my, I'm doing this to myself.
I'm going to give it a five.
I don't know if I would be
comfortable with taking that shot
through the windshield
portion of a helicopter.
Bullets act funny when they hit objects,
and the first object
that bullet is going to hit is that glass,
and because it's curved,
it's going to deflect the bullet
up or down, left or right.
There's really no determining factor
as to where that bullet's
going to land at.
So one shot, one kill for
that helicopter scene,
not so much.
From underneath the car,
that's actually a good thing to do.
I've shot from underneath various vehicles
and structures and stuff like that.
Especially in an urban environment,
you're going to encounter so much debris
and rubble on the battlefield
or where you're fighting from,
so you have to make do with what you have.
The only issue was her hand
placement on the rifle.
Like, she already has the bipods.
I don't see a need to have her hand
underneath it supporting it as well.
It's just extra weight
dangling for no reason.
I would've probably had
my support hand closer
or holding the buttstock
into my shoulder pocket
as opposed to that.
During sniper school,
we were always told to
call in an airstrike when
up against another sniper,
because it's really tough to
take out or fight against.
I believe she's shooting,
like, a 7.62-caliber round,
which is well within the capabilities
of taking out a target at that distance.
The odds of it being dead
on at whatever range he was
would've meant that she would've had to
know that distance ahead of time
and kind of dial in her scope for that.
Instead, she just stuck it on there
and pulled the trigger on the head.
It's not really like that.
But other than that, I
think she did pretty good.
Given the circumstances,
I would've probably done the same thing.
But I'd give it an eight.
She looked really calm behind it.
And some of the best
snipers I know are female.
Ooh.
Yeah, so this movie is based
off of an actual sniper,
Ms. Pavlichenko.
She was credited with over 309 kills,
and as far as putting that
bullet through the tank
like that, I don't know.
I've only aimed at a tank one
time, and it was by accident,
and I was quickly reminded,
don't do that again,
when they pointed the big cannon my way.
She went into her bubble.
Carlos Hathcock, a Marine Corps sniper,
called it getting into his bubble.
That's what she's doing
when all these mortar shells
and explosions are going off around her,
is getting into that bubble.
Being able to shut that
outside world off of the chaos
and calming down and ignoring everything
to pull off a shot.
I can relate to that 110%.
No. So, bullets don't travel
in a straight line like that.
They travel at an arc, even at 100 yards.
So to win that battle,
you have to aim higher,
causing the bullet to go up
and hit its apex point and fall back down.
All snipers are just like
really good NFL quarterbacks.
He's throwing it up and they're
falling into the target,
and bullets work the same exact way.
Because it was based on a true story,
I'll give it a nine,
not a 10 just because
the bullet trajectory.
Females, women make the
best snipers out there.
New shot.
Team: Abandon selective targeting.
All targets are now free.
The distances he's shooting
from, that's very plausible.
Here it looks like he's
maybe at most 150, 100 yards away.
Less than that, because
he's shooting down,
so less than 50 yards possibly.
The scope is not bad either.
I'm used to mil-dot scopes
and Horus reticles,
and they look like busy Christmas trees
without the lights on
inside of sniper scopes.
It was a very simple reticle.
Shooting in a crowded
environment is extremely tough.
During the International Sniper
Competition that I attended,
that was one of the challenges,
was to shoot moving
targets amongst a crowd.
It's extremely hard to do,
but our distances were way further
than what he appears to be
shooting, by, like, a lot.
At the angles he was
given and the distances,
it's not that complicated.
Just worrying about where
the bullet's going to hit
after you hit your target
would be my only concern.
Because they're in so close
proximity to each other,
he has a possibility of getting hit too.
I would give it a solid eight.
It's highly realistic.
The scopes are always messed up.
I don't understand why they
just don't put a real
scope reticle in there.
So, this is a actual spotting scope,
similar to what the individual
or the sniper's using in the movie.
And he's using it pretty correctly,
like, he's using it for target detection,
to identify where a threat may be.
He noticed a little bullet
on the ledge of that window
and then, you know,
finding things that were out of place,
that didn't make sense,
and eventually finding
where the sniper was.
It's something you see rare in movies,
the actual use of target detection
and how important it is for a sniper
to find the smallest details
and things that are out of place
to find who they're looking for.
What you want to do is be
pushed back away from the hole
and not put the barrel
protruding outside of the hole.
Gives your position away and
alleviates that whole purpose
of why you made that
hole in the first place.
I'll give it a seven.
I love the use of target detection,
but he messed up putting
the barrel through the hole.
Hey, everyone, Jay Ly here.
13-year Navy explosive
ordnance disposal, or EOD, vet.
Did four combat deployments,
three to Afghanistan
and one to East Africa.
That thing is apparently
the Cadillac of trolleys.
Can I say 100% that this
wouldn't be entertained?
No, because it might, but what I do know
is there are probably a dozen other ways
to attack this device from inside the bus.
I mean, something rudimentary
as getting a stick with some film,
so we can take an X-ray of the device
so we can actually see what's going on.
Harry: Jack, I'm going to
need you to look at the wire.
Harry, it's covered.
He is talking on a radio and/or a phone
right next to this thing.
It's electronically initiated.
They don't know if that energy
will cause that device to fire or not.
So that whole thing is
not realistic whatsoever.
I can't bypass! It'll fire.
S---, it's a collapsible circuit.
Yeah, collapsing circuits are real.
There's two or more detonators,
and when you cut one,
the other one will fire.
It's common for us to train to that.
It's very unlikely to encounter that.
In, well, at least in
Afghanistan, in my experience,
we didn't encounter a lot
of collapsing circuits.
It was mainly pressure
plates, stuff like that.
Very simple circuits.
Officer: Howard Payne,
Atlanta PD bomb squad.
Jack, I want you to get
out of there and sit tight.
We're going to go after the source.
No, they should 100% do
something to this device
and not just solely rely on
the bomber helping them out.
There are tools we have
to disrupt an IED and a component,
so it'll disrupt the firing train.
It'll disrupt all the circuitry
and separate components remotely,
and then we'll go down,
check the disruption,
and then separate components
further and do our thing.
Jack, I believe he is
a bomb-disposal officer with the LAPD.
He should know these
component-recognition things
and be able to identify
how this device works,
or at least have a good idea of it.
This definitely gets a zero
because he knows better,
and he should have taken an action.
He should have brought a
tool down there with him.
He could have taped it right next to it
and disrupted that
thing right off the bus.
We got under three minutes
left. What do I do first?
Pressure sensors. I
activated it when I sat down.
If I get up, my car explodes.
This is already hokey because he sat down,
and now it's armed. And there's a timer.
In movies and TV, they often
incorporate these big timers
where it's counting
down to the detonation.
But in all reality, it's mainly
a safe-and-arm-type mechanism.
If I'm a bomb emplacer, I
need to be able emplace it
and then safely get away.
So there's a timer,
but you're not going to
see this giant clock.
It's like, "You have five
minutes before you die."
Orange, yellow, green.
Colors don't matter. What
I need you to do is tell me
which one is hot to the touch.
The warm wire versus cold wires,
you can make a circuit
with the proper resistance,
so none of the wires are warm.
So, like, the movie
tropes of the warm wire
or the colors of the
wires is a total farce.
I can go to Home Depot, Lowe's,
whichever hardware store,
your hardware store of choice,
get any color wire I
want, and put it in here.
Take the small box out of
the kit and turn it on.
That kit probably looked like something
I would pull tools from
in a special-operations-forces
environment.
From my experience in Afghanistan,
it was all special operations forces
or naval special warfare.
We flew in helicopters somewhere, landed,
and ran to a target, right,
or walked a great distance
to get to a target.
You really want to limit
what you have on your body.
So, yeah, we're not going
to be carrying around
briefcases and backpacks
just full of tools.
Just cut it in the middle.
The orange wire between the two clamps.
I don't want to get into
that specifically in detail
because that is how we
attack certain things.
But yeah, those clamps,
they're for a very specific
purpose for multiple detonators,
and you would need another
item that he doesn't have there
to do diagnostic work
on that type of device.
You would need a little bit more time,
I mean, a lot more training
than just him saying,
"Oh, yeah, clamp it on the warm wire
and then cut in between it."
There's a lot of testing you have to do
before you can cut a wire.
But yeah, the whole setting,
him sitting down in it,
arming it, and then
having this opportunity
to render it safe, yeah, you wish.
So yeah, we'll give him a
two. We'll give him a two.
How it was set up and how it
was in place, totally legit.
He had a Claymore.
He put it on top of the Grand
Slam bomb, huge British bomb.
Claymores are used all
over. They're already wired.
They're premade to be
set up as booby traps.
That's what they're for. So
he just had the trip wire,
put something that he thought
one of these people chasing
him, idiots, would grab.
There are 100% bomb-detection dogs,
and in this clip, those dogs, I believe,
are going for human detection.
They're going for sniffing out Rambo,
not necessarily sniff out
explosive hazards in the woods.
And even if they were, those
dogs are running full speed.
That's like essentially
you trying to sniff
a hot dog in the corner while
sprinting down the hallway,
like hyperventilating essentially.
It's never going to happen.
Would the blast wave be that extended?
I mean, it was drawn
out to have that effect.
The explosive component
in there is torpex.
They added aluminum into the
composition of that explosive
to extend the blast.
But with that being said,
that's like a nuclear blast wave
that is just kind of continuing to go out.
It would be really big and done.
That blast wave would've
killed a lesser man.
Not John Rambo.
The explosive component
in there is torpex.
It's about 50% stronger than
TNT. And that's only the blast.
Frag goes exponentially
further than blast does.
So yeah, he is definitely within that.
This is probably the most realistic clip
as far as how things function
and how people think.
Man, I might give "Rambo" an eight.
He's knocked two because of survival.
That's hokey at best, even for John Rambo.
I got it!
It's a cylinder cipher! D-U-N-N.
It's my last name. It knows who I am.
If someone is just going to make
an improvised nuclear
device like this cipher,
anything is possible.
There's many ways that
nuclear weapons are armed.
Can't get into any specifics.
There's state-sponsored,
and then there's non-state-sponsored.
State-sponsored are going to have
all kinds of different protocols in place,
safeties, what have you, arming sequences.
Non-state-sponsored, if someone is just
going to make an improvised nuclear device
like this cipher, it can be
armed when it hears your voice,
when my voice, whatever the case may be.
Benji: I speak without a mouth.
I fly through the air
without wings. What am I?
An echo.
That's it! That's it, that's it.
Ugh. I can't. I can't even with this one.
This is ... he's talking to it.
How does he know if he
answers this question,
it's not going to go off?
It's empty.
Apparently it was a mud suck, right?
A hoax IED or a hoax device.
In real life, hoaxes are actually
very common, very common,
especially in Iraq and Afghanistan.
They were utilized
as intelligence-gathering
devices, essentially.
They'd put it in the road. Totally fake.
Just something that would
key up an EOD response,
and then they would be watching
and videotaping the whole procedure.
Despite all of the craziness
that was in the scene,
using a hoax to gather
intelligence on people
and to learn more about
them, absolutely true.
We'll give this one a eight,
up there with "Rambo."
Oh, God.
We would clown this movie
so much in training.
Like, we would just
pretend we're this dude
and just do the most outlandish s---
because that's exactly what he did.
He's attacking a VBIED,
which is a vehicle-borne
improvised explosive device.
Walking up to a VBIED without a tool,
an explosive tool, an
energetic tool, or anything,
not even a pole line or anything
to prosecute this vehicle,
is just dumb.
He went downrange in a
bomb suit with a crowbar.
I mean, cool.
They would probably send a robot down
with a tool first, right?
Especially because yeah,
that's a lot of HE.
A VBIED is no joke.
I mean, even the guys on the
wall, his security element,
they'd probably die if
that thing went off.
What the hell is he doing?
Dead.
He could have died a half
dozen to a dozen ways
in this clip alone.
Not to mention the whole movie.
Kicking it, randomly
opening the trunk by hand,
opening the hood by hand,
turning the windshield wipers on,
yanking random wires underneath the hood.
Like, any one of those could
have set that thing off.
Yeah, I think he removed his headset.
Please put your headset back on.
The most realistic thing in
there was the radio thing.
He actually took his headset
off so he could focus
and get his thought process going.
And then when they asked
him to put it back on,
yeah, that's probably the
response that you'd get
from an EOD tech.
We definitely render safe IEDs by hand.
I've done it,
and it's not ideal.
We want to go as remote as possible
because of the risk of
something going off.
But yeah, he could have done
a lot more with his hands,
like cut that cord,
detonating cord right out of the gate.
I forgot how many 155s,
but that's what was in
the trunk of that car
once he saw the main charge,
and that's what he should
be going after anyway.
Just reckless abandon.
Yeah, it's totally Hollywooded up.
The only realistic thing was
the communication aspect of it.
He gets a one. One out of 10.
Three miles underwater,
the water's crystal clear,
so I mean, that's ...
no, there's no way.
My fourth team, I was on a
mine-countermeasure team,
but it was underwater sea mines
and underwater IEDs and stuff like that.
This is supposed to be a nuke
that has fallen into the abyss.
It's a big deal when we go
to 200 feet of seawater.
We're definitely not going to
do free ascent to the bottom.
There's always descent lines.
We establish a safe area.
Yeah, he doesn't have any
search tools whatsoever.
He just has his eyeballs and
a flare, which is insane.
And that's just the diving aspect,
so we haven't even gotten
to the EOD part of it.
Hiram: He made it.
Oh, my God.
We'll go step by step.
The communication is totally wazoo.
It's three miles underwater.
What RF signal can penetrate
three miles' worth of water?
We do have very rudimentary
ways of communicating,
i.e., a float on the top of the water
that's connected to us via a
line, and we'll just pull it,
and the certain number of
pulls means a certain thing.
So we communicate like that
in a bottom-line-centric environment
where we're taking seismic
and magnetic precautions.
But yeah, nuke, that is a
totally different ballgame.
You have to cut the ground
wire, not the lead wire.
Without getting into any super specifics
on nuclear-weapons design,
we would've researched this ordnance item:
this is exactly how you render it safe,
if we want to separate components,
separate the fuse from it.
Sometimes we do that explosively,
sometimes we do it mechanically,
and then we'd just raise it
up and bring it to the beach
and exploit it on the surface.
I'd have to give that a big
fat doughnut for realism,
a zero, because that's not at all
how nuclear weapons function.
Here! McIntyre, can you hear me?
I love this show. It's so funny.
Unexploded ordnance, UXO.
Those are very common because
sometimes fuses just dud out,
and it's still a threat
because we just don't
know the condition of it.
Why did it not go off?
Is it a time? Is it a proximity thing?
Is it a delay that just
hasn't gone all the way yet?
So, very much a concern,
less so for everyone
else that's behind cover,
but mainly for the guys
that are right on top of it.
Heartbeat's regular.
[hissing]
You spring a leak?
It stopped ticking.
It is definitely plausible
to use a stethoscope
to examine a suspected clockwork fuse.
Seems hokey, but yeah,
that is old-school legit.
It was a thing.
For old bombs like that,
they had clockwork mechanisms in the fuse
that you could hear ticking down.
We don't see that a lot anymore.
That was a lot of training in school,
just to get the exposure to it.
It's a propaganda bomb!
Leaflets are definitely employed.
They were dropped in all over Europe
during World War II.
They were employed in, I
mean, North Korea, Vietnam.
Leaflets are definitely a
type of psychological warfare
or even just a means to
communicate with a population
that just is confined to an area.
But yeah, I'd give it a
solid seven for realism.
Granted, two random people
would not be working this bomb,
but yeah, so we've gotta
dock it a little bit.
I just don't know why they didn't have any
bomb-squad people.
So, on the side of the timer,
there should be a serial number.
That'll tell me which
wire y'all need to cut.
"Archer" here is showing
an inexperienced person
being coached through this whole ordeal,
like many other movies and TV shows.
It would be almost impossible
unless it was set up
exactly how the manufacturer
wanted it to be set up.
If that's the case, totally doable, right?
I can walk you through
anything. It's like, OK, cool,
how many wires are there,
what colors are they?
You ready?
Lana: God dammit, Archer!
First letter is B.
Bravo.
Thanks. Second letter is --
M as in Mike?
Oh, my God, that is so spot
on as far as communications,
especially when s---'s hitting the fan.
Oh, I can relate.
You have radio frequencies,
you have interference,
you have distance, you have
other things in the way,
so your signal can be degraded.
Everyone is getting
ramped up in this episode,
but in real life, when stuff is going on
and comms are an issue,
you just really stay calm
and cool and collected on the radio.
That way, even if it is a weak signal,
you can still hear what's being said.
Archer: I'm doing it, God!
Lana: Oh, my God. Ray!
Ray: What's going on?
The timer sped up!
The trope here with the
green wires being cut
and speeding up the
clock is just erroneous
because it makes no sense to
have that feature in there
unless you're trying to
create some type of anxiety,
and in real life, trust me,
if you're faced with a live explosive
that can detonate at any action,
keeping that at bay is already
going to be difficult enough.
So yeah, at the end of the day,
people want their things to go off.
So that's how they make them.
I'll give them a four.
The communication piece, that
was hilariously accurate.
Bombs aren't on the same fire line.
I have to defuse them individually.
How long is that going to take?
I gotta find them and then
dismantle them. 30 minutes.
There's just, like, a chunk
of high explosive taped to a pipe.
EOD would see that and,
boom, and make a call,
and everyone would get out of there
except for one other person,
him and one other security person,
and then I'm going to take
immediate action on that device.
And immediate is immediate.
It's not 30 minutes.
He was using a mirror for whatever reason.
I'm not going to use an inspection mirror
when I have my eyeballs and I
can see all the way around it.
So yeah, that's kind of hokey.
He's got NODs on his helmet,
so that's cumbersome,
especially when he's working on that one
that was at head level.
His NODs could hit it,
and if there's an anti-move
thing on there, boom.
He just functioned it, as designed.
So I would take my helmet
off, so there's nothing,
no obstructions that could
potentially hit this device.
If he's the only one there,
yeah, that's what he's got to do.
It's because it's threat assessment
of what's going to kill me right now.
That's an enemy combatant.
He's probably going to
kill me if he sees me.
So that needs to be taken care of first.
But yeah, he would have
at least one shooter with
him a little bit away,
so when I'm working, I
can be focused on this.
They could've classed it up
a little bit, but all good.
Bingo.
He did use ceramic scissors at the end.
I thought that was a nice touch. Granted,
he used ceramic scissors
instead of diagonal cutters,
and typically when wires
are coiled up like that,
there's two of them, and he cut them both.
He could have smooshed the two wires
that are conductive
together and set it off.
Yeah, there's a lot of hokey stuff.
So yeah, it's gotta be low. Low three.
Towards the general
direction of the mountain.
The robot rarely finds
what you're looking for.
They're in Helmand, which,
I was also in Helmand.
Helmand Province in Afghanistan.
And yeah, robots are awesome.
I didn't see the robot
go down with a tool.
Tool in, tool out, that's what we do.
That's what's preached
from day one in EOD school.
The robot has cutters
on it, it has grippers,
it can separate components,
whatever the case may be.
And so if it did find something,
it could countercharge it
or they could set it down.
No!
At the end of the day, that
is what a robot is for.
They're expendable devices.
If worst comes to worst,
they find something by functioning it,
it blows up, not a human being.
The entire team was standing
out in front of the vehicles.
That's totally not what would happen.
They would be inside their
vehicle driving this robot.
That way, you have mitigation
from fragmentation coming at you.
At least be behind the
vehicle, for God's sake.
I need you to keep your head still.
Don't nod.
This is a clothespin switch.
Very old and very rudimentary,
very easy to defeat.
Nick, the EOD operator,
should have seen that.
He identified that it's
a pull. Cool. Cut it.
Just cut it and be done with it.
But he did the thing of holding his head.
You tell someone that
they're connected to a line
with a bunch of explosives,
they're going to freak out.
That's one of the rare times
where you can actually attack a switch.
It's a very clear cut.
That could have been
handled way differently,
and then everyone would've survived.
It's tough. A lot of EOD
procedures and tactics
are written in blood, just like this.
The survivors are like,
OK, this is exactly what they encountered.
Over the radio, this is what was said.
Now we have our new set of TTPs
so it doesn't happen again.
I'll give this one of
five. It's got some stuff,
some super-hokey stuff,
but all in all, not bad.
John: What are you doing?
Batman: I can get it out over the bay.
The plausibility of having a bomb
that is unable to be rendered safe,
it's all a matter of time, really.
If time is not an object,
then yeah, you can spend
the time and the diligence
and really get it disassembled
to where it's demil'd.
So now you have to weigh,
can I render this safe in a
minute and 30 seconds or not?
And the answer's probably no, right?
Because especially with a device
as sophisticated as
that was supposed to be,
your best case is you have a minute and 30
to get this as far away
from everyone as possible.
Yeah, water has a great tamping effect
because it cannot compress.
It really depends on what
the actual explosive,
the nuclear yield of this bomb was
and how deep it was able to go.
The mission of EOD is protection
of personnel and property.
So yeah, getting that device
out in a way, moving it,
relocating it, even if
it's to your own demise,
is what we would do
for the sake of protecting
personnel and property.
Is it a nine? Can Batman be a nine?
I'll give it a nine.
I like to think his actions were genuine
of Navy EOD.
Hey, my name is Dakata Brodie.
I'm a 21-year military veteran.
I served 13 years in the US Coast Guard
as a search-and-rescue-helicopter pilot
and eight years in the Army
as a UH-60 Black Hawk helicopter pilot.
All right. Tuck them in, boys.
For the Coast Guard, primarily,
we face offshore and going off shores
to effect most of our rescues.
However, the Coast Guard does train
for vertical-surface rescues,
which is what you're seeing right here.
Cliffside, cliff rescues,
and everything else.
Just stay perfectly still. I
have to stabilize the car, OK?
Hurry!
Rescuer: Car secured.
All right. If that is the hoist hook,
you are in what you call
a committed situation.
Every helo pilot would be
shaken at this point right now
knowing that the hoist hook
is attached to a vehicle
that could fall off.
Not happening. We're not
connecting up to any vehicle.
Joby, I'm coming down.
Harrison, you're flying.
So, a pilot going to the back seat?
First of all, you know how
much stuff you can knock off?
You could literally turn
off both of your engines.
The fact that your vest
and everything could snag
and you could flip things off.
We actually had a person
turn with their NVGs
sitting on top of their head
and actually hit one of the engines
and knock an engine offline with that.
So, yeah, it's very possible
to actually turn off
something inadvertently
just climbing and trying to
get to the back of the cabin.
Pilot: Out the door.
Natalie, don't you worry. I'm
going to get you out of here!
If I am outside the helicopter,
we have a real bad problem.
As a pilot, I am never outside.
I got you!
Cut it!
Joby, swing!
They were trying to show, like,
the hoist was holding the truck up, right?
The hoist that you have
on there about 600 pounds.
So it's not your primary
means of holding up anything.
At that point that it was
smoking, it was straining so hard.
Now, there is a squib that
you could flip the switch
to actually cut and
shear that hoist cable,
which is what they were
doing at that point.
So somehow they sheared the one cable,
and The Rock and the other
person was on a different cable.
I don't know what that is.
I'll say that our helicopter has one cable
that we're going to operate with.
Once that cable gets sheared,
everything is going down with it.
It's not going to happen
on so many different levels
on this clip.
This right here is a zero.
Pilot: Where are they?
Tanker's on the way.
Air Force rescue 231.
I don't know why nobody wears NVGs.
Everybody has NVGs on,
night-vision goggles on,
in the helicopters. Nobody wears them.
If you have the option of having them on,
yeah, you're going to have them on.
The fuel probe that you just saw,
that's not a standard piece
of equipment on helicopters.
There's just certain helicopters
that are either doing
some long-range rescues.
Most helicopters do not have that.
Pilot: No!
Your biggest thing at
that point is if you miss,
where's that tube that's
going that's flowing fuel,
if you're going to cut that
thing with the main rotor,
you're talking about damage
to the main rotor system.
You'd be in a bad spot at that point.
Looking right now at a lightning strike.
Knock on wood and thank God
I've never had that happen.
You risk frying a lot of electronics,
engine-control systems that are on there.
You're hoping that your
engines are staying online.
You would probably lose
a lot of electronic
AC and DC systems inside the helicopter,
but you should be able to keep flying
unless you got hit in the
tail rotor or something.
Every year, the Coast Guard has to do
what's called dunker training.
So we get flipped over
in a chair in a pool,
which simulates having to ditch.
You're rolled upside down.
You have to do multiple different egresses
to show that you have the proficiency
to be able to get out of
a submerged helicopter.
Every single year, and
then every six years,
unless they've changed
it, but every six years
you would go to actual school,
where you go through the
whole mock-up simulator
of a device going in and rolling over.
So this is a part of the business.
He's got SEAs bottle or HEEDs bottle,
which gives you about two to
three minutes at normal breath.
In that mode right there, you
have about 10 to 15 seconds
if they're breathing the
way I think they are.
But the pure shock of going in
and the water temperature itself
is going to take the breath out of you.
But I do like the realistic aspect
of seeing somebody grab that SEAs bottle
and put that thing in their mouth.
Now, for everybody that flies,
we have emergency jettison handles.
So the normal exits are no longer
going to get you out of the door.
It's too much pressure that's
on that door at that point.
So you're literally hitting
your emergency jettison
like it's blowing cartridges,
and the door pops off.
It just is lifting up the
actual door-hinge pins
out of the way so you can create
that full opening at that point.
Anybody's going for that,
yeah, you're going to die.
I'd give this one probably about a six.
You can lower me down.
I'll get the two men.
You return and pick us up on my signal.
The theatrics on there is amazing.
They had no business being that close
to a rig that's exploding.
So, we've done multiple
rescues in the Gulf of Mexico.
I was stationed at before.
So, flying out to rigs,
rigs typically have burn-offs happening,
but there's always either gases
or stuff like that that's coming off.
So the rigs all have more of
escape-type pods and things
for the rig workers to be able to get out
and be able to get off of the rigs,
and then we would effect the
rescue from the open water.
To try to go into there again,
we're no good to anybody,
and it's so much risk
of that flying debris,
shrapnel going through
the rotor-blade system.
You're just now a victim.
You're not going to put yourself
or the crew in that situation.
Rescuer: Count five.
Five.
Any standard deployment
of the rescue swimmer,
they're just going down.
At that point, you just
call it a direct deployment
of the rescue swimmer.
Especially when you're deploying somebody
either to a boat that's underway,
you'll have them down,
you'll have them just off
the water or just above.
But to say that you were
about to send somebody
through a flame, a blowtorch in essence,
not gonna happen.
Rescuer: One!
When somebody is on the cable,
the hook is actually locked
just to prevent any mishap
to where it could inadvertently come open.
For somebody to pirouette
and unhook themself off of the cable
at the same time, that's pretty amazing.
Nobody would be that crazy
to even attempt to put
somebody in that situation.
The rescue swimmer would come up
and slap everybody in the helicopter
for even putting them down
in something like that.
So absolutely not.
It's completely
unrealistic. That's a zero.
Pilot: Swimmers away!
When he jumps from the helicopter,
that's a free-fall deployment
of the rescue swimmer.
That is reserved for daytime only,
so we would've only hoisted
the rescue swimmer down
at that point, not let him
jump from the helicopter.
They're seeing, like, 20-foot
swells or something like that.
That means the helicopter is hovering
at least 30 to 40 feet.
You misjudge that swell, that's
a four- or five-story drop.
That water turns into a solid real quick,
especially if that was cold temperatures.
I have the ready-for-pickup signal.
Basket is going out of the cabin door.
Basket is in the water.
It's a standard rescue basket.
He's calling for the basket,
has the ready-for-pickup sign.
That's exactly what you would hear,
because we're standing by,
keeping our light in the
direction of the swimmer,
kind of making sure we
always have sight on them.
And as they're getting ready,
you're going to try to place the device
really within about
five to 10 feet of them
once they're calling for it.
So very, very real.
Pilot: How we looking on fuel there?
Crew: Bingo, we're at bingo. Gotta go.
We're out of time. We gotta go, Carl.
That "bingo" fuel, that's a real term.
It just means if you leave now,
you will land with a fuel reserve
when you get back at your station.
Anything that's less than there,
you can be at risk of either not making it
to your destination or
airport or flaming out.
It's always a race against
how much fuel you have.
Go, go! Behind you!
Hurry!
When you're seeing the winds,
that rotor wash, it's beating down on you,
it's a mini hurricane underneath it.
There is no communicating
with the swimmer in the water
at that point in time.
All hand-arm signals.
That would be insane to think
that you're going to hear a person,
a swimmer in the water
underneath a spinning helicopter.
Not gonna happen on there.
Holy s---!
We lost our tail rotor!
The waves out there, that's
in the Arctic, kind of,
where I believe that
scene was taking place.
20-, 30-foot seas, and even
having rogue waves can happen,
but you try to be above that.
The explosion, that's the Hollywood part.
I've seen helicopters crash on
tarmacs and different things,
and I haven't seen one explode.
Even in the Army, I saw one take a SA-7
and hit the engine out.
That was the only one
I saw that was on fire.
I would give it a seven.
It's the Coast Guard.
They must have picked
up the distress call.
Pilot: Swimmers ready. Deploy swimmers.
So far right now, you're
seeing pretty much
a legitimate helicopter rescue.
It's daytime. You can free-fall
the swimmer in daytime.
Their altitude was good,
where the swimmer could safely go out.
The swimmer's going to have
their goggles, everything down.
They're not going to
free-fall with their gear up.
They go in the water, they're
going to lose all their gear.
So they're going down.
They're going to cover
their mask and everything
as they're going in.
The device going down and being placed
about five feet from them in the water,
that's just textbook Coast Guard
rescue-swimmer operations on there.
When you have baywatch,
that's really the LA
County's fire department.
They're aka baywatch here
in the Los Angeles area.
We hoist with them routinely.
The rescue swimmer could easily
just bring them over to the vessel.
The fire department, they're
trained paramedics as well.
Primarily, you're going
to try to put people in
with the least-risky rescue method,
which would be to put them on the boat,
unless they had sustained something else
that they needed immediate transport,
bring them in a helicopter
and transport them to
the nearest hospital.
But the rescue in itself,
that's pretty textbook
for what you could see
if you're going to free-fall
the rescue swimmer, yes.
It's a nine, just because
of how the rescue swimmer
had his goggles and
stuff on top of his head.
I love the precision flying of that.
This is the MH-68 or AW109, the Stingray.
Really what you'll call for HITRON,
which is our helicopters
tactics interdiction.
It's a specialized unit that we have that
primarily their focus is
interdicting either drug smugglers
or anything else like that
in international waters.
Mostly dealing with drug smuggling,
what you'll call a go-fast.
It'll typically outrun a boat.
Your normal cruise is somewhere around
the 120 to 130, 130 knots,
if you really got a good
tailwind and stuff like that.
Watch out, he's got a weapon on board.
Bail out! Bail out!
I've never been at HITRON.
I did fly airborne use of
force with the Coast Guard.
A lot of times what you're trying to do is
we're going to try to stay outside
of what they have on board of there
and make sure we can at least maximize
the use of our weapons systems.
Coast Guard, take them down.
They went for the kill shots right there.
So, normally they're going to probably
put some stitches in the water.
They say "stitches in the
water" because when you see it,
it looks like stitches from
the machine gun going out.
That's kind of just to escalate the level
of the use of force at that point
before they try to shoot the engines out
and really are more so trying
to just disable the vessel.
That's primarily what they're doing, yeah,
is disabling the vessel.
So I'd give them about a seven.
At any point in time you're committed,
you have something that's attached
to something that can pull you down,
that's just the worst situation
for a helicopter, right?
So you're just at the mercy
of being on that pivot point
and just completely helpless.
Wet, slippery hand conditions,
trying to hold on to a
ladder with adrenaline
and the amount of rotor wash.
It's a mini hurricane down there.
So you're holding on
with quite a bit of grip.
So I'm pretty sure you're almost probably
bear-hugging the ladder at any point
just to try to maintain your grip.
We're going to stall!
Cut it now!
Mercenary: We have a job!
Pilot: We're going to
die here! I said cut it!
They were actually doing
well talking as a crew
for saying get rid of it.
That's a tough call.
It sounds easy to watch
the movie and say that,
but that is a really
hard call to say shear.
Even when we're getting ready to start
any hoist and rescues,
like, "Hey, if this happens,
you'll say 'shear' three
times, safety power system
or the flight mech, you
race for that shear button."
It was an eight for how dynamic
that environment would be.
The stretcher. We call it a litter.
Anytime we're going to use a litter,
we're going to use a trail
line to help stabilize,
because that flat plane
surface that's underneath
with all the rotor wash that's down below
will really have a good propensity
to have somebody start
spinning really quick.
I'm not sure what was causing
the pilot to struggle so much.
He's got the whole ship to
look at as far as in reference.
Power really wasn't an issue.
It almost looked like they
were making the hoist cable
feel like it was somehow taking
power away from the engines.
I don't know.
Having a fouled cable or watching
a cable actually birdcage,
that part is real.
That can happen, so it could
go in there and not be.
You can't let out some
more cable at that point.
I don't understand why the
pilot was struggling so bad.
I'm not sure.
At this point, what's got a hold of them
is some good bait that's
clearly under there
for whatever is eating on them.
So there's no need to take
the whole helicopter down.
Shear, shear, shear.
We'll have to preserve the
lives of the rest of the crew.
There's nothing else you could do.
This is more of a three.
Please don't shoot the
flare at the helicopter.
We see the flare in
the distance. Trust us.
If the flare gets on the raft,
it'll start eating through.
It's, like, a phosphor material,
so you're shooting hot phosphorus
at the thing that's trying to rescue you.
You're trying to take us down with you
at that point in time.
The flare is meant to be
seen, not to be caught.
We just want to see the flare go up
and then find the point of origin
so we can come and effect the rescue.
A lot of times, if we're going out,
it's more likely just one helicopter.
I'm not saying you can't have two.
If it's a longshore rescue as well,
there's a fixed wing asset overhead
that will probably go out and do
really good radar sweeps
inside of the area
and try to help us. And
they'll also be able
to drop and deliver any
type of rescue materials.
Certain helicopters do have radar systems,
so we're trying to either
see a blip on the radar,
or we're trying to map the
shoreline when we're out there
in really poor weather conditions.
Helicopters have a few different lights.
So, each pilot have their own searchlight,
and then a lot of times you'll operate
with what's called a Nightsun.
So it's just a really powerful searchlight
towards the middle or
the back of the cabin.
This right here is probably a 9.5.
Hi, I'm John Spencer.
I'm the chair of urban warfare studies
at the Modern War Institute.
I spent over 25 years in the US Army,
but I've been studying urban
warfare for over a decade.
It's very accurate to be behind a wall
and you pop out for a second
to throw a grenade like that.
Where he's throwing the
grenade is a little off.
Grenades have a timer in them,
basically, so they don't
blow up in your hand.
Once it hits the target.
It's not throw, explode.
100% air support is that
vulnerable in urban operations,
and why usually you don't bring it in.
It's low-flying, it's slow,
it doesn't have much protection,
and usually you drop soldiers
offset of the urban battle.
In this situation, they didn't expect
that level of resistance.
Go.
Crossing the street can
actually be one of the most
vulnerable things of urban warfare
because there's so many angles,
so many windows, so many doorways
which you can get shot.
So we teach things like
throwing smoke out there
so that people can't see
you and going one at a time
and mixing up the speed
at which you're going.
If I didn't know this battle,
the battle of Mogadishu,
I would say that this is not realistic
where you have hundreds of
people shooting at a small unit,
but that's really what happened.
And they got the soldiers pretty accurate,
but there's been a lot of
criticism about this movie
and the depiction of the
Somalis and kind of the context
of what's going on in
Mogadishu at this time.
Hey, Grimes, stay away from the wall.
You OK?
Yeah!
That's actually an iconic
scene, when he says,
"Stay off the wall."
That was real advice
because once the bullets
are hitting the walls, then
they travel down the wall
kind of like a bowling alley,
and it can hit if you're standing on that.
I wouldn't say it happens in all,
because every city is different.
You have mud, cement, glass,
metal is a little different,
but that's real.
Let's go, Maddox.
You see the bullet holes in the glass
because back then we weren't as prepared
for urban warfare as we are today,
so those aren't bulletproof vehicles.
A lot of the weapons
there aren't really ready
for that environment
that they're moving into,
but they also were surprised
by what they encountered.
So I'd give it, like, a nine
from realism in urban warfare,
not realism in the
portrayal of the population
and things that are going on.
Chris Hemsworth is more
like Jason Bourne there
with his hand-to-hand.
Close-quarters fighting is
very common in urban warfare.
We actually tie the weapons to ourselves,
so if we get caught in that situation
and turn a corner or
somebody grabs our weapon
they can't take it away from us,
but not the tactics that
you're seeing in that scene.
He's surrounded by
people with bigger guns,
so he's trying to disarm one
while another one's there.
Personally, I would have
tried to disarm one of them
with one of those rifles
and then get your back against something
so you're not expecting
a bad guy 360 degrees
and then incapacitate them in some way.
I can't say I've found
myself in a similar situation
or we teach that, but it could work.
Absolutely slow the person
down, buy yourself some time.
I'd say you'd want to turn
corners as much as possible,
and especially in a building like that,
just to confuse them
on which way you went.
Out of everything out of that scene,
that's probably the most realistic.
The fact that he's hiding behind a column,
that column is a supporting column,
so it has steel-reinforced concrete.
Where some walls, it can be
paper-thin, it can be plaster.
If you don't have that, then you do get
behind things like
furniture and other things,
anything you can to try to get you cover.
Yeah, it was a lot of fun to watch,
but I'd give it about a
one or a two in realism.
I actually love this clip,
and I wish I could show
it to more soldiers
to think about buildings differently.
Especially if you're defending a house,
you want to take the stairways away,
you want to take the doors away,
and absolutely throw furniture down.
But the scene is really great
too because it shows you that
that's not necessarily
what you stay behind
to protect you from bullets,
because bullets pass through wood,
through cloth and everything.
That's a great lesson
that clip teaches you
that we teach our soldiers,
is to stay away from windows.
You crouch down to go underneath them,
kind of slowly walk your way around them.
Bullets incoming probably
wouldn't be that dramatic,
but like that, absolutely we tell you
to stay away from windows.
Yeah, that clip is really important
to what people don't even think about
even in the military, called mouse holing,
putting holes in walls, in floors
to move throughout without being seen.
It's very common in major urban battles.
Actually, I would love for
soldiers to carry an axe
or something like that, but
there are other ways to do it.
Sometimes we use
explosives, sledgehammers,
axes like that to make that hole.
Real tactics, real everything,
so I'm going with a
nine on that, actually.
I mean, this scene seems
very familiar to me
because I had my own deployments
to Iraq and to Baghdad
where we were doing raids like these
where there's only a few terrorists
in a population of millions.
For the advantage of your
equipment, you can see at night,
but also to reduce the
risk of being observed
and the risk to civilians.
The fact that their night-vision goggles
were always on top of their
head is not realistic.
You'd want to cut the power or
eliminate the light sources,
so you want to use those
goggles to your advantage.
Execute.
It's very common and very smart to have
a sniper with overwatch who has angles
that the people moving
into the house can't see.
It's a really good call for the sniper
to be the one to execute the first shot,
because you want to save your
surprise to the last moment,
and a sniper usually
has a silenced weapon.
This sniper in particular,
he'd probably be wearing more equipment,
and usually it's a sniper and a spotter,
so there'd be other people with him.
The way they enter this
house is a very common,
almost too common, thing
that's portrayed in movies.
It's called enter and clear a room.
Throwing a grenade can
be the preferred tactic
if it's known to be an enemy location
and you know there's somebody
in there with a weapon.
Of course you're going to enter it
with something other than your face.
So, the way they're stacked on the door
is about getting in there quickly.
It actually evolved from SWAT tactics.
These tactics were actually developed
to limit that amount of violence
because there may be
civilians intermixed in there.
The tactics you see Bradley
Cooper employing there
is what I would teach.
You want to get behind
something that's going to stop
the bullets that people
are shooting at you
but also be able to return
fire. We call that cover.
The windows are great to get down behind,
kneel behind, still shoot from.
Unlike the enemy in that scene
running out into the open areas,
that's actually the opposite
of what actually happens.
They're going to stay inside the rooms,
make you come in there.
You're going to get off
the streets and the alleys.
Butcher's on the move.
Repeat. Butcher's on the
move. I'm in pursuit.
When he goes off by himself and chases,
that's not realistic.
We don't move by ourselves anywhere.
It's almost like a cardinal rule.
So it would be another team
person right there with him
and communicating to each other using
some type of radio or something.
If he says, "Moving," then somebody else
would follow him out there.
I'd give it a rating of around an eight.
Ambush!
This happened to me in Iraq,
ambush initiated by an RPG.
Ambushes are very, very
common in urban warfare.
It's meant to surprise the people,
entrap them in a funnel like that.
Although the bad guys don't usually
just stand on top of the roof.
You would not be standing
in the middle of the street
shooting back. You wouldn't last long.
We'd seek cover, use those
armored vehicles, which is great.
Ideally, though, in the whole situation,
it's called a "kill zone" of the ambush.
You want to get out of it.
That concept of having a,
we call it a quick reaction
force, a backup team.
Because you've been surprised,
somebody needs to come to help you,
and we usually keep forces
in their uniform ready to go
in an urban setting like this
to be that quick reaction
force to come to that aid.
Let's go. Let's go!
They ram the vehicle,
which is very common.
Trying to lock them in that kill zone
so everybody can shoot at you.
So, I'm actually going to
give it a higher rating
than I want to because
the ambush is so real
outside of the tactics, so I'll give it a,
let's give it a four.
The drones are probably
the most ubiquitous change
to urban warfare that's
happened in decades.
As I go into Ukraine to
research urban warfare right now
on the major battles,
there's thousands and
thousands of drones being used.
It reduces some of the
challenges of urban warfare
if I can put a drone
in front of the soldier
to see around that corner,
to see over that building.
The aspect of X-ray vision,
we're not there yet,
because we still can't
see through concrete.
Especially not much can see through steel.
It gave me a lot of feelings
of real stuff that's happened.
Especially the use of the dump truck
reminds me of the Beirut bombings
where a dump truck was brought
to the front of the base,
like in that scenario, but then exploded.
This is why urban warfare is so hard.
Dump truck could be a threat.
Although that's probably unlikely
that you're going to use
your vibranium shield
to throw it up in the air,
but what it signifies for me
is what we call a three-block war,
where, when you're
fighting in urban terrain,
you are actually very concerned
about the civilian population
and protecting people
at the same time as you're fighting,
and there's restrictions on
what you can or can't do.
So, no, that's a very plausible scenario
that any soldier who has values
is trying to protect
the civilian population
while still trying to do it, the mission.
So if the rating has to be for realism,
I'll give it around a six.
Eight to 10 Tangos, front gate.
Left! By the trees.
A couple little things in there.
There are nice touches of
adding realism to the situation,
like the red dot that
you see on your scopes
on the modern weapons that
will kind of help you aim
to the green hue that
you see on their eyeballs
coming off the night-vision goggles.
So, when you see some version
of night-vision goggles,
kind of martian type of look.
When you look around,
everybody's got green eyes.
Get to the top of this building. Let's go.
Blocked by buildings.
We got no vantage point.
This roost is a bust.
In this scene, they enter
a really strong building
like that. It's a great idea.
The strategy was called strongpoints,
or a building that is really strong,
it has lines of sight
or directions you can fire
from in multiple directions,
and in war it's happened
where a single building
has been held for months
just because it was the right strongpoint.
He says it's a bust because
depending on what type,
the direction, the building,
and where the enemy is,
they got up there, thought
they'd have good vantage point,
but they couldn't see
anything, so it was a bust.
Take on your right.
What we usually see in
urban warfare movies
is everybody trying to get to the roof
because it kind of is common
sense that I can shoot down,
I can see people farther out,
but depending on the context,
you don't want to be
anywhere near the roof
because you can also be seen from the air,
from drones, from mortars, you can be hit.
It's based on a real situation
that happened in 2012
at Benghazi where they're
attacking the embassy compound.
That's a good idea to get up there
so you can see where they're coming from
and to take better
shots and not waste ammo
from the rooftop for sure.
I'd give that a pretty
high rating in realism,
about a seven, eight,
just based on the type
of weapons, the tactics,
the chaos, the building
construction. It's pretty real.
I think this is an important scene
because one of the biggest
myths that TV and movies show
about urban warfare is
that it's just infantry
or soldiers shooting their weapons.
Major urban battles are tanks, artillery,
engineers, infantry.
They're full-scale battles in concrete.
Now, the damage that the
tank does to the building,
that is unlikely that just
the whole face of the
building is going to fall off.
It's going to do a lot of damage,
and that's why you have a tank,
because a tank is mobile
protected firepower.
It has that giant gun that can
punch through that problem,
which is concrete and cover.
But in this scene, they're all tracers.
It's almost like a "Star Wars" ray gun.
They won't all be like that.
There's actually a myth that tanks
are not helpful in urban
warfare, they're too vulnerable.
But actually, the
history of urban warfare,
if you go into a major urban fight
and you don't have a tank, you're wrong.
But the problem is that
the tank can't go by itself
and the infantry can't go by itself.
And as we see in this scene,
the infantry worked to protect the tank,
and then the tank protect the infantry.
But tanks are vulnerable, as you see here.
The Germans shoot from below
where the tank can shoot,
in the basement.
The size needed to take a
town or a village or a city
all depends on what the
enemy is that they're facing,
and I think they really didn't know.
For that street,
I think that looked
about right, absolutely,
where you combine a tank
section, always two tanks,
with an infantry platoon or something
to clear a street like that
before you discover where the enemy is.
Outside of the lasers of the rounds,
this is a very realistic
scene of high-intensity combat
and the combined arms that you need,
so I give it a nine.
Ugh. Will you pause?
The one thing that I can't
help myself on this scene
is that everyone walks up to the wall
and just sticks their rifle
over the top of the wall.
That's absolutely what you don't do.
You're just putting a flag
up saying where you are.
I don't have any problem with
them moving to the rooftops.
This is a hasty attack.
Two different buildings, that's great;
it gives you converging fire.
So firing down from two
different directions.
They can cover more of the courtyard.
The scene in this movie
is based on the real
battle of Mosul that happened in 2017,
one of the biggest battles
really since World War II,
100,000 security forces
against a entrenched ISIS enemy force
that had to be cleared out.
That's actually pretty realistic.
You open an attack like that
with your biggest weapon.
We call it the most
casualty-producing weapons.
Duds do happen. The way
you usually get around that
is you have more than a
single point of failure,
more than one big weapon,
or, like they do here,
which is actually accurate,
is once that duds, that's it.
Your surprise is gone. Attack.
It's actually pretty complex,
what they're trying to do,
because they have moving forces
with other elements shooting down
that they have to know
and watch very closely
on when to turn their
fire off as you advance.
That's, in some ways, the
way I would teach it as well,
that's as they're maneuvering in
while another person's holding them down.
Booby traps are very
popular in urban warfare.
Pictures on the wall. Any and everything
could be potentially booby traps.
We see it right now in the Ukraine war
when Ukraine takes back their
territories from the Russians.
But you have to be hyperaware
of all those booby traps, for sure.
One is just awareness of every soldier
not to move and displace things,
and then we have bomb-sniffing
dogs that we'll bring in.
I'm going to actually give
it around a five, six.
Just some of it's a little off.
He'll be on the footwalk over the gutter.
We'll take him out from behind.
The underground is a huge component
of that three-dimensional
aspects of urban warfare.
Many cities have cities under the cities,
and in battles like this,
which, this movie is based on
the battle of Stalingrad,
which was called the "Rat War"
because there was such
a prevalent underground.
Yes, those are possible
urban sniper positions.
The characters on both
sides are loosely tied
to real snipers that were prevalent
in the battle of Stalingrad who were known
to put themselves in the barrels
and the ventilation shafts.
The cat and the mouse
between the two snipers,
that didn't happen.
We do train soldiers
to use the environment,
and there is some aspect of
manipulating light and smoke.
That's a real thing, right?
Reflective lights in the mirror,
but you don't know where the sniper is,
and unlikely that you're
going to have that ability
to blind that, so, no, don't do that.
I want to give it a
higher one because it is
pointing out the
underground warfare aspect,
but the realism of the
actual, this happening,
around a three, I guess.
That's pretty about as real as it gets.
The IED, or the improvised
explosive device,
is the weapon of the last 20-plus years.
The invisible enemy that you
couldn't fight back against.
The M2 .50-cal is still used today.
It's a very effective large machine gun
that has the size of bullet
and penetration of concrete
that you'd want, where
other weapons might not.
The accuracy of what
the bullets were doing
to the building looked pretty accurate.
Some of them you can
tell aren't penetrating.
He didn't shoot that
many bullets at that wall
to create that level of sprawling
and honeycombing of that wall.
The tactics there are pretty sound,
where you have the machine
gun covering an upper level
while the infantry are maneuvering lower
so there's control there
and positioning themselves
to enter that building where
they know the enemy is.
I can't say that kicking
of the door is not real.
It's called a mule kick.
I wish the movies would stop showing it
because it's not effective,
but I have found many soldiers trying it.
But it's not the most force you can put
by kicking in that door.
You want to face the door.
Soldier: On the ground!
[civilian crying out]
That's an unfortunate
but very realistic aspect
of that scenario and that chaos
of when the soldier enters the room,
but controlled and not
just firing at everybody.
But then you have scared,
frantic civilians even approaching you,
making the soldier feel very unsafe.
That's a very realistic and
impactful traumatic situation
that is urban warfare.
So if we were to take out the mule kick,
I would give that scene a 10.
Gareth Timmins here.
I'm a former Royal Marines commando
that spent time in
Afghanistan, Egypt, Somalia,
and just various places
around the Middle East.
Gas!
It's CS gas, which has been widely used
in the Middle East, especially
around the Arab Spring.
Whether you would fire it
out mortars is another thing.
Firing the CS gas and
having it airburst like that
would just be like
chucking a little cap
of bleach into the sea
in terms of its effectiveness
on trying to poison swimmers.
Mine!
I mean, if you were
breaking contact like that,
you would absolutely just,
I would've thought, just
drove in a straight line
as fast as possible to get out of there.
But they seemed to veer into it just fine,
I think for the purposes of the film
and for the viewers, really.
The fact that they're just
perfectly placed on the top
is quite comical, really.
A minefield would normally be set out
in a certain way to
either restrict movement
or to channel the enemy
into a particular point.
In terms of the spacing
and the mixture of mines,
it's just been placed
there just for the vehicle,
just to hit it.
The anti-personnel mines are actually
now banned by the Geneva Convention.
What used to happen with those was
you'd trigger one of the pines,
and they'd come out the ground
at about waist level,
and then they'd detonate.
But yeah, you wouldn't normally
see them on top like that,
unless there'd been a sandstorm,
but even still, they look brand new.
If you were breaking contact
or trying to get away from the enemy
in an open desert like that,
with no kind of life support --
you've got no urban
environment, no buildings --
you would absolutely want
to stay in that truck,
unless it was completely disabled,
and at that point you had no other option
but to leave it because it was
acting as a magnet for the enemy.
But you certainly wouldn't bail from it
if it were moving.
Improvised explosive
devices that were used in
Iraq and Afghanistan do flip vehicles,
but whether a mine would be able
to flip it to that extent is debatable.
But certainly the people
that were inside it
would be severely injured, if not killed.
I'd give it a 3.
Yeah, they're in the desert,
they're in military vehicles,
there's military kit getting used,
but apart from that, it's
very loosely based on reality.
Radio: I have seven
Mexican police vehicles
located at the border checkpoint waiting.
They're moving and forming
up in your configurations.
They're really, really closed up now.
Before they got to the border,
when they were driving in
urban areas or built-up areas,
that kind of convoy posture
would have been perfect
if you want to maintain the
posture and the security
and not have vehicles come in.
But as soon as they've kind of left that,
and they're going now into
the open desert and open ground,
they would want to really,
really extend the spacing.
The Humvee, it's an awful vehicle.
It's not comfortable.
During this now, you would close up,
because you've got limited visibility.
It's exaggerated there, really. Yeah.
It is a thing.
It would restrict your view, absolutely.
Radio: No vehicle, no motion.
Oscar 1. Incoming on your right.
Man: Air, I see nothing.
Radio: Contact right.
I think it's realistic.
You would have put out
"contact right, contact right,"
which is what they do. Again, it's good.
There's, like, natural,
generalized chat in there
about the weather and whatnot,
and that would happen in real life.
There'd be some jokes,
there'd be some banter,
but you would be very much
focused on the job at hand.
So the communication there,
in terms of communicating
to the whole group, is good.
It could be a bit better, but it's good.
Man: I don't see anything.
Oh, down, down!
[gunshots]
You would absolutely, at all cost,
want to drive through that.
We call it "driving through it."
They call it "the killing zone."
To stop in that or be disabled in that
would be like your worst nightmare.
The sound and the impact that
that round would make on the windscreen,
I think would naturally,
despite your training,
just make you do that.
I think once a few rounds hit it
and it had massaged your anxiety of
"nothing's going to come through,"
you would like to think that you'd be able
to get back on track
and push through that.
It's just, it's chaos.
[gunshots]
It's what's called a complex attack.
The first guys go out to the left,
which is what you would
do on a contact right.
You would get out on the
left-hand side of the vehicle
and use it as cover then
to try and get some
rounds off if you had to.
You're always told in training
to get out of the side,
naturally, that's not taking fire.
So you'd get out to cover.
And you can see how they're kind of
getting the weapons into the shoulder
and how they're manipulating the doors
and then pushing the door and coming back
onto the stock of the weapon and stuff.
It's really high-level stuff
and weapon manipulation and use of cover.
It's absolutely superb.
[gunshots]
I wouldn't want to be
under there, as a soldier,
because you'd have no view whatsoever
of anything that's going off,
and it would be claustrophobic.
I can see why she's done
it, un-military-trained,
but it's not where I'd want to be.
You've got to try and get
away from that killing zone
somehow, as soon as possible.
I'd give it 9.
The only kind of thing
that lets it down, really,
is the spacing when they're
going to open ground
in terms of the vehicles,
but apart from that,
how they react, the weapon manipulation,
the communications is really good.
He's running around often
with a top off or a vest on.
The sunburn and the heat stroke
that he would get from
that would kill him.
You'd have some kind of
a camouflage shirt on,
or a tactical jacket, like a thin jacket,
and you'd almost certainly
have body armor on.
Depending on the sand,
sometimes it's soft,
and it would be incredibly
difficult to move.
I mean, granted, he's got
no kit on, no body armor,
but it would be incredibly difficult.
You're running from side to side
to evade possible enemy fire,
especially if that's
coming from behind you.
You'd be running to positions of cover
rather than in a straight line.
It's there to look like a Hind.
It's actually the Pumas
that have been modified.
They've been marked up to look like
real Soviet gunships,
yeah. They were introduced,
I think, by the Russians in 1972.
So they definitely would have been in
the actual Afghan and
Russian war in '79 to '89.
The biggest myth, really, is,
I think about desert warfare films,
is, I think, the hero
journey that one takes.
So it's, if you look at, say, "Rambo"
or anything like that, it's
kind of a one-man band.
One person getting
injected into a theater,
into a war zone,
and in reality it's just,
it's wholly not possible.
That weapon system, .50-cal Dushka,
it would take it down.
It absolutely would.
And I'm just slightly unconvinced
that there would be,
A, enough rounds for it
for that amount of time.
Sometimes you can get
one or two rounds off,
then you have to start
doing your stoppage drills.
One person could operate that, yeah.
Would be better with two,
but one person could.
It's a difficult one because
everything that happens
is in the realms of
possibility. It really is.
I would probably give it a 5.
I think the percentage of
success that he would get
from doing what he does
would be very, very small.
Call it in. See if there
are friendlies in the area.
Lima 2 Charlie.
The radio operator has
tried to establish comms
via the sat phone.
He's not been successful, but he's not
give the responder opportunity to respond.
We've used them before in
Somalia and other places.
It's just a case of sometimes moving
to an elevated position
or a different location
to establish communication.
They are unreliable.
Who are they, man?
I don't know.
You would have automatically hit the floor
and gone to ground, and
you would have started
observing from what we
call your belt buckle,
from a prone position.
The mirage effect, obviously
it's a thing. It's there.
But it wouldn't distort
the images like that,
and you'd still be able
to make people out.
Their movement towards
you, it's very relaxed.
They're not running, they're not shouting.
You'd be looking for
weapons or weapon systems
as they start to get closer.
Form a line!
They do get into extended line,
which is good tactically
for this scenario,
but the posture that they get
into, the hostile posture,
getting weapons and
getting them ready to go
into the shoulder, is an escalation
that you would want to try and avoid.
See, and they're all M16s.
Some of them have got
underslung grenade-launcher attachments.
It's an old American-issued weapon.
They'll be real weapons with probably
just magazines in, with no ammunition.
Soldier: What are you doing?
Swoff!
Guys, cover him.
Weapons should have been down, for sure.
He should have had one of
them just put his hand up,
but just posing a more
peaceful kind of approach.
Maybe saying, like,
the local language
in terms of a welcome
would have been the right
course of action to take.
He walked straight into the arc
of the line of fire of all the lads.
You would never do that.
He would have almost
certainly been killed in that
if it would've gone ugly.
Realism, I'd probably give it about
a 5 or a 6.
It's not uncommon for people to walk
into your arc of fire or your line of fire
and just be unaware of it.
In this instance, you would try
and scarper away to
cover in a low profile.
Going to grounding
straightaway is good drills.
Try and lower your profile.
But trying to get into some
form of cover would be ideal.
I know it's difficult in this scene.
It's very open, and
there's no built-up areas
or anything like that.
But your tactics in this would be to,
if you have to engage, engage,
but then try and peel away.
Yeah, it'd be a worst-case scenario.
It's a Minimi that the guy's got here,
which is a key tactical team weapon.
A belt-fed 5.56 ammunition.
But just how he's holding it,
it's up, and then he holds the back stock.
He's definitely been taught that.
The drills in this as well,
we call it "the rate of fire."
The people with the rifles, the M16s,
are firing single shot,
which for accuracy is great.
A massive thing in Hollywood is
our weapons are always on
automatic, fully automatic,
and it's not really correct.
Although the drills are good and slick,
in this you can't get away from the fact
that it looks like actors holding weapons.
Probably give it a 4.
I think the SAS, in
reality, would have done
things differently. A lot differently.
I don't think you would have engaged in
preemptive strike like that,
unless they were literally
coming towards you and upon you.
The dog is clearly sniffing
for explosives, IEDs.
Putting them in the ground is
to identify areas to avoid,
but they might also be put in the ground
just to show the allied
forces where they can move.
But they would sit down, yeah,
when they've come across something
that they're not that happy with.
They're expecting a treat.
What it's kind of all about for them,
it's just a game.
[ringing sound]
In terms of disorientation,
like the ringing nose alluding to
how your ears would be, absolutely, yeah.
You might not hear anything for minutes.
Might burst your eardrums.
I mean, it is realistic, but they just
seem to recover too quickly from it.
Could be an old shell,
an old war shell that they've used.
Pointing really towards a vehicle,
like a vehicle IED that they've
kind of detonated there.
The fact that it's actually on
what looks to be like a common trail
for vehicles and stuff
kind of points to the fact
that it would have been that.
I think it probably might
have been a greater explosion,
a bigger explosion, but it would
blow them back like that, if not worse.
Canine error would be a factor
that you would factor into
it, especially if you've
not kind of run the dog
over that area as well.
Hey! How did your dog miss that?
You could've gotten us all killed.
It must have triggered the
bomb from those houses.
It's all really good
until after the explosion.
There's no way that you would be kind of
up on your feet and calling somebody out
for what they have or haven't missed.
You'd be glued to the
floor, you'd be shocked,
you'd be disorientated, and
you'd just be scared to death.
There's no way that you would kind of
respond in that kind of manner.
And another thing that
you've got to worry about is
that might just be the first detonation.
There might be a secondary explosion,
and I think if somebody has detonated that
with a command wire,
which is what's happened,
you would absolutely be expecting
an ambush off the back of that,
because you've actually
got people watching.
I think it's really realistic
up until what happens after the explosion.
And for that, I'd probably give it a 7.
So, the red smoke is to indicate
the LZ, the landing zone,
where you're going to
extract somebody from.
Slightly strange in this clip,
because it's almost self-explanatory,
given that you've got
helicopters just above it.
So it's kind of just thrown out there,
probably visually just for
the viewers of this film.
It would have been an incredibly
aggressive kind of posture now
from the rescuing forces.
They wouldn't waste any
time trying to decipher
whether you've got weapons
or whether you're a friendly.
There's just no time for it.
It's just quickly in and out,
so everybody in between them
and extracting the US personnel
would have --
it wouldn't have been a great experience
for them whatsoever.
Let me see your hands!
The Americans, or anybody,
will always go back for one of their own.
You would have had guys
on the ground for weeks
days before, providing
CTRs, close target recces,
of this and establishing patterns of life.
What kind of weapons they've got.
What time they go to bed.
Where they're keeping the hostage,
and if they keep moving him.
And that would have been getting fed back
in order to create this rescue attempt.
So the first phase of it
probably would have been
the Spectre gunships that you see
and the Apaches coming in,
followed by the ground
forces following up behind.
Soldier: Are you Marcus Luttrell?
You're safe, Marcus. You're going home.
What they could do is probably
ask him his service number.
"What's your service
number? What's your name?
What's your rank?" and stuff like that,
which would quickly identify him.
So it's true to life,
right? It actually happened,
so I've got to give it a 9 or a 10.
Trey: Got movement. 12
o'clock, about 300 meters,
two guys on the roof.
Ortega: Are they armed?
Trey: I don't know.
So, these are US Marines.
There's kind of two sides
to the communication.
The initial start, where they're saying,
"Have they got weapons?
Have they got weapons?"
It's to identify them as
potential enemy targets,
but also it gives them, in a sense,
a free pass to engage, if they have to.
Looking for weapons is
the combat indicator.
It's a simple f---ing question, Trey.
Do you see a weapon?
Trey: Negative!
That's not the question you asked.
You asked if they were armed.
The answer to that one
is I don't f---ing know.
Obviously they're f---ing armed, Ortega.
Why else would they be
running around up there?
I don't f---ing know, do I?
I don't understand these f---ing people.
I think the chatter is
Hollywood. It's unrealistic.
In real life, it'd be very minimal.
And especially the swearing as well,
I think this is probably a bit tame
in terms of what it
would be like real life.
Certainly, the immature nature of it
is definitely inaccurate.
Trey: All I know is we
need to see weapons.
[gunshots]
They're not really using
cover well, and, yeah,
they don't really move
position in between firing.
Once they take that first shot,
they should move position,
and especially if it's a sniper as well,
'cause he'll just be looking
for you just to pop back up
in the same position,
and he'll be on target.
Kevlar helmet.
They are effective in
protecting your head.
It all just depends on
the caliber of bullet
that the helmet's hit with, the angle,
and also how close it is
from leaving the barrel
to hitting your helmet.
If it's a sniper, which, you could argue
it is from that range and
picking shots off like that,
they would have kind of
a long-caliber bullet,
like a 7.62 long, firing
out of a bolt-action rifle.
It might protect him based on angle,
but if it is a sniper,
from that distance as well,
they would probably be getting, like,
hits towards the center
of mass or on the face,
but it would protect him.
What the viewers need to appreciate
is that it would be incredibly,
incredibly uncomfortable
to have your head above that
knowing that somebody is firing,
because all you can really think about
is that in not even a second,
you could be hit in the face
and that might be you just
completely turned off.
So you are uncomfortably aware of that.
So, yeah, I think you would
be a lot further down.
Where are you hit?
On the f---ing eyes!
I mean, he might have had sand kick up
from the round that he
wants to just get out.
It's probably the right
course of action in that instance.
He might've had a bit of
material from his helmet,
if he's been shot in the
helmet and stuff, so yeah.
I'd give it a 5
just because I think the
chat is kind of unrealistic.